SEVERAL ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO
EXPLAIN THE NEW PROCESS SEES
THAT WE'VE DEVELOPED TO
CONTINUE OUR ESSENTIAL WORK
DURING THE PANDEMIC. FIRST LET
ME START BY THANKING MY
COLLEAGUES ARE STAFF AND THE
PUBLIC FOR THE PROFESSIONALISM
AND THE COMMITMENT THAT IS
CARRYING US THROUGH THIS
UNPRECEDENTED TIME. WE
CERTAINLY FACE CHALLENGES WE
WEREN'T SURE HOW TO MEET AND I
pELECTED PUBLIC SERVANTS WE'VE
DEPLOYED AROUND THE STATE TO
HELP AND REASSURE OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND EVEN OUR OWN
FAMILY. IF LESSEN OUR BILL
LOADS ALLOW US TO FOCUS ON HOW
TO WHETHER THIS PANDEMIC. AND
HOW TO FOCUS ON THE BUDGET. SO
TODAY- WE'RE GOING TO SHARE
SOME TIME WITH TWO OTHER
DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANTS WHO
ARE HERE TO PROVIDE A SENSE UP
INTO THEIR WORK. AND HOW
THEY'VE ADJUSTED AND CARRIED ON
DURING THE PANDEMIC IN LIGHT OF
THEIR RESPECTIVE
RESPONSIBILITIES. BUT FIRST I
WANT TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE TECHNICAL SIDE OF THINGS
FOR TODAY. LET ME ON BEHALF OF
OUR STUDENTS REFER ASK. ALL
SPEAKERS COLLEAGUES WITNESSES
ALLY. SPEAK SLOWLY. AND EIGHT.
EIGHT ALSO. IN RESPONSE TO THE
CODE NINETEEN AND PROTECT THE
PUBLIC SENATORS AND SENATE
STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL THE THING SO IN
COMPLIANCE WITH OUR STATE AND
LOCAL ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING.
MADE IN THIS AREA JUST MONTHS
TO NORMAL PRACTICE IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC HAS
ACCESS. TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. BOB CONDUCTING THE
HEARING IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS
THE HEALTH AND THE SAFETY OF
THE PUBLIC AND OUR EMPLOYEES.
OR HOLD IN OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING- IN THE CAPITAL WITH
ONE OF OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING- AND HEARING
REMOTELY WITH THE USE OF VIDEO
CONFERENCE SYSTEM AND THAT
WOULD BE SENATOR BATES. SENATOR
BATES I KNOW THAT YOU'RE MORE
FAMILIAR THAN MANY OF US WITH
THIS NEW TECHNOLOGY SO JUST ONE
REMINDER TO YOU WAS WE GET
STARTED. ADD TO PLEASE MEET
YOUR PHONE OR COMPUTER. ANYTIME
YOU HAVE A COMMENT OR QUESTION
USE THE RACE CAN FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. AND EACH TIME YOU'RE
ACKNOWLEDGE TO SPEAK. UP WHEN
THE WILL YOU'RE ACTING IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO MEET PLEASE
SELECT ON MUTE. BEFORE BEGIN
SPEAKING AND R. I. T. PERSON
PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN
YOU'RE DEAD. OUR TO ALLOW THE-
PROCESS WE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. HEARING ROOMS TO
THE X. THAT THIS OR ALLOW. AND
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY.
FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND WILL BE
PLAYED ON THE SCREEN TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER. EIGHT FOUR
FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR. AND ENTER THE ACCESS CODE.
ONE FIVE EIGHT SIX. NUMBER IS.
EIGHT FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR AND THE ACCESS
CODE. FOUR ONE FIVE EIGHT EIGHT
SIX EIGHT. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT A MODERATOR WILL
IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY WELL
OPEN YOUR LINE AND AT THAT TIME
YOU MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY. AND
WAIT FEEDBACK MUST USE THE
DEVICE OR WHAT THANK HEARING ON.
PRIOR TO GIVING YOUR TESTIMONY
OVER THE PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I
HAVE A FEELING OF US ARE GONNA
BE EXHIBITING SOME PATIENTS
TODAY. I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUALS
WERE DISRUPTED MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE NEEDING.
SERVICE OR HAVE YOUR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. EVERY EFFORT
HAS BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS A CONDUCTOR
HEARINGS. IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
MAYBE I'M LATIMES FOR. BUT A
JET TO THE NEW ONLINE TOOL. SO
AGAIN BE PATIENT. EVERYONE CAN
BE. AND WITH THAT ARE BEFORE WE
BGIN TODAY'S AGENDA MADAM
SECRETARY LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM AND A REMINDER TO
MEMBERS YOU WILL NEED TO TURN
YOUR MICROPHONE ON FOR THE ROLL
CALL. AND EVERY TIME THAT WE
VOTE MADAM SECRETARY WE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. NINE YOUR MONEY
HERE ROB HERE ROUGH HERE WILL
PRESENT PRESENT ATKINS HERE
HERE. SECRETARY NOTES A QUORUM
HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED AND AGAIN
REMINDING EVERYONE THAT SENATOR
BASIS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
FROM HER DISTRICT OFFICE TODAY
SHE WILL BE PARTICIPATING IN
COMMENTS QUESTIONS AND DEBATE
SHE WILL NOT BE VOTING. SO
LET'S START AND A FIRST IF I
COULD COLLEAGUES I'D LIKE TO
DISPENSE WITH ITEMS TWO THROUGH
SEVEN BEFORE WE GET TO THE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT. AS A
REMINDER THESE ARE COMMITTEE
MEMBERSHIP CHANGES TO REFLECT
THE ELECTION OF SENATOR
MELENDEZ AND TO FILL THE
VACANCY THE CHANGES TODAY WERE
ALREADY MADE RARELY THERE ARE.
FOR PANDEMIC TODAY'S ACTION IS
TO RATIFY AND- WHAT
APPOINTMENTS PERMANENT I DON'T
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN. I HAS BEEN MOVED-
MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON ITEMS TWO
THROUGH SEVEN. RUNNING BACK ON
I ROB I'VE ROTH AYE WILK I LOOK
I AT HI ATKINS I ORDER HERE THE
IS FOR ZERO FIVE THOSE. ARE OUT
THEY YOU CALL. SO NEXT WE WILL
TAKE A GOV SUPPORT BEGINNING
WITH MERRY BILL AT PRESIDENT OF
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. I'LL LET ME SAY
WELCOME OF PRESIDENT BADGER IF
THERE IS AND WE SEE YOU ON THE
SCREEN THERE IF THERE IS ANYONE
WITH YOU THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE I WOULD WELCOME THE
INTRODUCTION THEN IF YOU WANT
TO GO AHEAD AND MAKE OPEN
PROMISE. ARE PLEASE FEEL SO AND
THEN I WILL SENATE FOR COMMENT
QUESTION WELCOME. YOU CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE HEAR YOU WERE.
YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT I MEAN IS
THERE AND- THANK YOU AND
MORNING PRO TEM AND THE SENATOR
OF THE ROLE COMMITTEE. MY NAME
IS VERY REAL BAD CHAIR AND AS
THE PRO TEM SO I'M THE- AT I AM
PRESENT COMMISSIONER. AT THE
CALIFORNIA YOU COMMISSION.
THANK YOU MUCH FOR THE AVERAGE
TO BEFORE YOU TODAY. WHEN I WAS
BORN IN LAST AUGUST I
UNDERSTOOD THE ISSUES THE
LEGISLATURE WAS GRAPPLING WITH
COULD BE CENTRAL TO MY WORK.
FOR THE FIRST NINE MONTHS OF MY
CPUC DURATION. IT WAS LAST
SUMMER THAT A SECOND ROUND OF
MAJOR WELFARE LEGISLATION WAS
PASSED BY THE LEGISLATURE AND
INDEED SIGNED EVAN. ANY AND ALL
HELL OF. EACH OF OUR MAJOR.
TRICK IN THE- ON UTILITIES WAS
UP SIR WITH THE LARGEST THEM IN
EARLY STAGES OF BANK THE- AN
THERE WERE SOME. DOUBTS. UC'S
SENSE OF. AND IT'S A TO AN TO
THE TECH. ANSWER AT IN THE A-
AND THE CLIMB AND- THE NEEDS OF
THE P. WE SERVE. THESE ISSUES
REMAIN FOR AND CENTER WE THIS.
BUT IN ADDITION THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY THREATS OF
WHILE. WE HAVE NEEDED TO CAN
AND RESPONSE. TO THE END OF.
USE OF POWER SHOT OFFS FALL AND
NOW WE PREPARE FOR THE
POTENTIAL IN A- OF THE KOBE
NINETEEN. THESE PHYSICAL
THREATS ARE NOT ARE NOT OUR
ONLY CONCERN THE ECONOMIC
DAMAGE CAUSED BY KOBE IN
NINETEEN IN THE SOCIAL IN
EQUITIES IT HAS HIGHLIGHTED. AS
ALSO REQUIRED FOCUSED ATTENTION
TO SUPPORT THE FINANCIAL
STABILITY OF THE HOUSEHOLDS
ACROSS OUR STATE IT IS CALLED
THE PLAN IS TO MAINTAIN AND
INCREASE ACCESS TO THE POLICE
SERVICES TO BECOME MORE
SENSUAL. DURING THE CALL PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS AS FAMILIES HAVE
MOVED TO SHELTER WORK AND LEARN
FROM HOW. I THINK WE CAN ALL
AGREE THAT THE PEOPLE WE SAW
HEAVEN AND- DESTRUCTION AND LAW
IN. MONTHS AND YEARS MORE THAN
EVER CALIFORNIANS SEEK FROM OUR
INSTITUTIONS INCLUDING THE CPUC
AND THOSE WE REGULATE TO LIVE
UP TO OUR DUTIES IN THE
COMMITMENTS TO PREDICTABLY
PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY SERVICE.
SAYS THEIR LIVES INDEED DEPEND
ON. THEY WANT CERTAINTY FROM US
IN THOSE MOMENTS WHEN
EVERYTHING ELSE APPEARS
UNCERTAIN. GOVERNOR NEWSOME ASK
ME TO SERVE IN THIS. WITH THE
HOPE THAT MY EX IN
UNDERSTANDING AND MANAGING
SECTOR ORGANIZATIONS COULD HELP
IMPROVE THE CPUS SEES ABILITY
TO THESE CHALLENGES WITH
URGENCY DOES REQUIRE. IT AND WE
HAVE MOVED FROM ONE DESTRUCTION
TO ANOTHER OVER THE LAST YEAR
MY ASSESSMENT OF THE CPC AND
THE RECENT CHANGES WE HAVE MADE
TO IT'S CALLED ORGANIZATIONS.
HAVE OCCURRED IN. OF RESPONDING
TO THESE ACTIONS CON APPROACHES
TO REGULATE OFF POKE ON LOOKING
AT WHAT HAPPENED YESTERDAY NOT
TOWARDS TOMORROW AT THE CDC WE
CANNOT REGULATE FROM BEHIND.
GIVEN THE RAPID CONSTANT
CHANGES IN THE ECONOMY CLIMATE
IN TECHNOLOGY MY FELLOW
COMMISSIONERS AND I HAVE BEEN
WORKING TO BETTER ANTICIPATE
MANY OF THESE CHANGES. I'LL
STOP AT ALL. ATHLETES USED WITH
DELAYED ENTITIES. IN THE EVER
TO CURB AND MEN. IN WE SEE
THROUGH THE OF LIFE OKAY. WE
ARE IN HERE IN OUR MODEL BASED
ON A ROOM RECORD INVEST AND-
ACTIONS. TO ONE THAT CAN DRAW
THE RATE ENTITIES IN REAL TIME.
TO ACHIEVE THE STAND AND OUT X.
IN THE AND RULES USED. OUR GOAL
TO PUT OUR DEFENSE AG INTO. AT
LEAST ENOUGH JUST THE PROBLEM
WHEN IT COUNTS SMALL. WE WERE
TO REALIZE THIS AND- AS WE HAVE
FAST TRACK TO STAY NEW WELFARE
RELATED RULES I OF THE MOST
SPIRITS OF THE WILDFIRES. AS
WELL AS THROUGHOUT SPONSORED AN
ACTION IS TO CUSTOM. FROM THE
FINANCE. IT MIGHT SEEM. ONLY
THROUGH ON THESE RECENT. YOU
THEIR CUSTOMERS AS REDUCE
MISTRUST AND ANGER I UNDERSTAND
THESE SETTLEMENTS AND CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES I SHARE THEM.
EIGHT MONTHS INTO THIS POSITION
I HAVE A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF
HOW THE SERVICES WE REGULATE
SERVE AS THE BACKBONE OF THE
STATE'S ECONOMY EVERY
CALIFORNIANS LIFE IS SERVED AN
IMPACTED BY THEM THIS IS ONE OF
THE FEW STATE AGENCIES WITH AN
ABILITY TO INFLUENCE VARIOUS
SECTORS OF THE ECONOMY WAS
COMMON SET OF VALUES THAT
REFLECT THOSE. YOU SIR. IF
CONFIRMED YOU'LL HAVE MY
COMMITTEE TO MAKE SURE THOSE
VALUES REFLECTED IN THE WORK WE
DO WITH THE CPC AND THAT THE
OUTCOMES WE PURSUE. OUR IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF THOSE WE
SERVE. I AM ACTUALLY HUMBLE TO
APPEAR BEFORE YOU TODAY AND I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
WELCOME YOUR QUESTIONS. HE SO
MUCH PRESIDENT BADGER. I WILL
GO TO COLLEAGUES NOW AND I WILL
START WITH SENATOR PAT BATES.
CAN YOU HEAR ME. WELL GOOD OKAY
THANK YOU- ALL CONGRATULATIONS
THIS VENTURE ON NOW YOUR
NOMINATION. YOUR OINTMENT SHALL
WE SAY AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE OUR I DIDN'T HAVE A
CHANCE AS YOU KNOW YOU KNOW
BEING OUT HERE IN THE DISTRICT
NOW THE REAL FACE FACE NOT THAT
WE COULD HAVE A FACE TO FACE
BUT I DO APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATION. ARE I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT THE HIGH USE
CHARGING THE IMPACT THAT HAS
BEEN ON OUR LOW INCOME RATE
HERE'S YEAH NOT MY DISTRICT IN
PARTICULAR AT THE- TIME OF
USAGE IS QUITE EXTENDED AND I
KNOW THAT CREATE US IT IS WERE
SOME SENIORS SO. WILL TAKE A
LOOK AT IN THE COMING YEAR
THAT'S BEEN SOMETHING ON I
THINK I. SAID THAT I KNOW ON
MANY. STATE ONE RIGHT NOW OUR
STATE. IS BEEN DIFFICULT FOR
THEM. GIVEN OUR YOU KNOW THAT
OF DAY THAT SORT OF THE ARE A
TO. YOU KNOW USE THAT APPLIANCE.
AND IN FALL IN THAT CHARGE.
AREA SO. HE'LL TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT AND SOUNDSTO ME LIKE YOU
ARE VERY COMMITTED TO.
RESPONDING TO THE ISSUES THAT
ARE. IT'S WHAT'S HAPPENED
CERTAIN YOUR CUSTOM HAVE. SO
I'LL BE LOOKING ON TO THAT AS
WE GO FORWARD I WILL BE
SUPPORTING. OUR AND FOR
CONFIRMATION OF YOUR NOMINATION
WHEN I'M BACK FOR THE BUILDING
SESSION. AND LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING A GOOD YEAR AND
HOPEFULLY WE ALL WILL GET
GETTING THROUGH THIS. ARE SO
MANY QUESTIONS ARE. AS YOU LIKE
TO SHARE WITH ME ARE WHEN WE
CAN HAVE. A ONE ON ONE I LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT SO THANK YOU.
AS I DO SENATOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU I TO MY
COLLEAGUES IF I COULD SENATOR
RALPH ALL START WITH YOU AND
JUST GO AROUND. THANK YOU MAYOR
PRO TEM UM. MA'AM PRESIDENT
CONGRATULATIONS. YOU KNOW I'VE
HAD THE GREAT PRIVILEGE OF
WORKING QUITE CLOSELY WITH. THE
PRESIDENT IN HER PRIOR
POSITIONS HERE AND SACRAMENTO
DURING THE EIGHT YEARS I'VE
BEEN HERE INCLUDING THE
REORGANIZATIONS OF THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION AND THE ISSUES
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES. HER TRACK RECORD IS
EXTRAORDINARY- I ABSOLUTELY
HAVE NO QUESTIONS AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO MOVING THE
CONFIRMATION AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
SENATOR ROTH MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO
NEXT SURE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
AND AGAIN- CONGRATULATIONS TO
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT ON ON THE
APPOINTMENT AND I TO LOOK FOR
TO- CONFIRM YOU WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE TIME I'M VERY UPSET
WE DID NOT HAVE OUR MEETING ON
MARCH SEVENTEENTH. THAT'S A
LIFETIME AGO NOW DOESN'T IT.
WHAT A WEIRD WORLD WHERE WE'VE
WE LIVE IN A WAY I DO HAVE I DO
HAVE A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS I
THINK WE'VE BEEN GIVEN THESE IN
ADVANCE BECAUSE SINCE WE DON'T
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET
TOGETHER. MY FIRST QUESTION HAS
TO DO WITH- PS PS THE TECH
FIRE. OCCURRED IN MY DISTRICT
IN A CHECK OUT TWELVE HOMES.
AND IT OCCURRED DURING ONE OF
THESE SHUTDOWNS AND SO THESE P.
S. P. S. PROGRAMS HAS GREATLY
IMPACTED THE SAFETY. AND DAILY
LIVING FOR CONSTITUENTS. DIO
YOU THIS IN MY AREA BRAG CITY
ONLY 2% OF THEIR SERVICE AREA-
CAME UNDER P. S. P. S. IT MUST
HAVE BEEN A 100% HI DISTRICT.
BECAUSE IT WAS PRETTY
WIDESPREAD. BUT MOVING FORWARD-
WHAT STRATEGIES IS THE PEACE
LOOKING. TO REDUCE THE IMPACT
OF THE PS T. S. ON RATE PAYERS.
THANK YOU MUCH WE HAVE DONE A
LOT AND IF I MAY LIKE TO TAKE
SOME SOME TIME TO- WALK
THROUGH- THE MANY THINGS THAT
WE HAVE DONE- ON PS YES
PREPARATION. THREE I OWE YOU.
INCLUDING THE I OWE YOU THAT
SERVICE IN YOUR TERRITORY.
THERE'S A LOT AND I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT SO I WANT T
WALK THROUGH THIS VERY
CAREFULLY STARTING WITH- LAST
OCTOBER- I ISSUED A LETTER TO
P. JEANNIE DIRECTING THEM TO
FILE UPDATES- WEEKLY I WITH
IT'S A P. YOU SEE. ON A SERIES
OF CORRECTIVE ACTIONS INTENDED
TO IMPROVE. PLANNING AND
EXECUTION OF THE P. S. TS WHICH
YOU ALREADY CALL WAS AND- WAS.
QUITE DISASTROUS ON OCTOBER
EIGHTEENTH I HELD AN EMERGENCY
MEETING- TO PUBLICLY ADDRESS
THE MISTAKES AND THE
OPERATIONAL GAPS IDENTIFIED IN
P. GENIES OCTOBER PS PS EVENTS.
THE P. JEANNIE EXECUTIVES OR
CALL BEFORE US AND EXECUTIVE-
CEO BILL JOHNSON APPEARED ALONG
WITH THEM. ON JANUARY THIRTY
YES I ISSUED A ACR AND TO- IN
MY DE JENNER DE ENERGY STATION
PROCEEDING WHICH ORDER P.
JEANNIE. ON TO UPDATE THAT PS
PS OPERATING PROTOCOLS THE
THINGS THAT I ASKED THEM TO DO
IS UPDATE THE OPERATING
PROGRAMS WITHIN FORTY FIVE
DAYS- WE COLLABORATED WITH- YES
AND CAL FIRE FIRE TO PLAN AND
EXECUTE YES YES- EXERCISES.
ESTABLISH WITHIN THIRTY DAYS
WORKING GROUP'S OF THE TRIBAL
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ACROSS
THE GENIE IS A SERVICE HERE.
AND THE NAME ALSO THE IS TWENTY
RECALLS USING THE FEET THOSE
WERE GROUP'S ON IN IN THE D.
ENERGY STATION PRO SEATING ON
GENERATE WE ISSUED AT THE FOR
WE ISSUED THE PROPOSAL FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT- ON APRIL TWENTY
SEVEN DOUBLES DECISION WAS
ISSUED- FOR COMMENT IN THE
GENERAL ELEMENTS OF THAT. WERE
TO RESTORE POWER AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE NO LONGER THAN TWENTY
FOUR HOURS AFTER ARE FOLLOWING
THE CONCLUSION YES AT AND CAN
BE. THE REGIONAL I WAS WORKING
GROUP'S WITH THE TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS- AND THEIR PAY
THEIR PUBLIC SAFETY PARTNERS.
COORDINATE ADVISORY BOARDS TO
CONSIST OF PUBLIC SAFETY
PARTNERS- CONDUCT PSCS
EXERCISES I MENTIONED EARLIER.
YES AND PLANNING BASED ON LOCAL
DEMOGRAPHICS AND SURVEY DATA
FOR THE FOR MEETINGS OF A
VARIETY OF SAFETY NEEDS FOR THE
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. AND WE
ON. I ALSO- WAS CONCERNED ALONG
THE WAY AND AGAIN I'M FOCUSING
ON P. GINNY RIGHT NOW AND I
DON'T ADDRESS IN A MOMENT THE
OTHER TWO- I OWE YOU. I FELT IN
JANUARY AND FEBRUARY AND EARLY
MARCH WAS NOT NEEDING MANY OF
THE THINGS THAT WE HAD
ESTABLISHED BOTH IN MY LETTER
OF OCTOBER FOURTEENTH LAID OUT
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT THEY NEED TO. TO BE
DEALING WITH AS WELL AS- SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT THEY HAD
PROMISED ALONG THE WAY THEY
WOULD BE DOING SO. I ASKED MY-
YOUR FOLKS HERE IT THE P. UC
CAROLINE JACOB THOMAS THOMAS
JACOBS SORRY AND- RACHEL-
HEATER SON. TO MEET WEEKLY. AND
HAVE THE HAVE PEACH WITH P.
JEANNIE IN ORDER TO REPORT
EXACTLY WHAT THEY WERE DOING
AND WHEN THEY WOULD HAVE THOSE
THINGS COMPLETED IN TIME WILD
SEASON SO- AT THE SAME TIME I'M
AT THE WHILE FIRE MITIGATION
PLANS BY ALL THREE I- USER
BEING SUBMITTED TO THE P. UC
THEY WERE DOING AND- FEBRUARY I
WAS DRESSED THOSE LATER IT. IS
NEEDED SO- WHAT THESE MEETINGS
HAVE HELPED US UNDERSTAND IS
WHAT AND WHEN HE JENNY AND TO
KEEP HER AND WE'VE EXTENDED
THESE MEETINGS WITH. WITH YES
AS WELL AS CAL FIRE MEETING BY
WE WITH OUR- SAN DIEGO GAS
ELECTRIC AS WELL AS SAN AS WELL
AS AND AS- SHOWN US THAT
FRANKLY THE GINNY'S CAISTER
SLIGHTLY BEHIND ON SEVERAL
THINGS THEY HAVE THEIR WEBSITE
UP IT'S WORKING PROPERLY IT'S
BEEN WELL TESTED BY CALIFORNIA.
TECHNOLOGY THEY ARE SLOW ON
THEIR LAYS ON AS BEING
ESTABLISHED WITH- THE- LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND TRIBES THEY ARE
GETTING MAKING HEADWAY THERE
EVER. IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE CAN
IS. THAT DURING THE P. S. P. S.
ONLINE EVENTS THEY HAD A VERY
DIFFICULT TIME GETTING
INFORMATION OUT OF-
PARTICULARLY EACH INNING AND
SOMETIMES ADDISON AS WELL. SO
THOSE LIAISONS ARE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO BE ESTABLISHED
WITH THE COUNTY AND THE
COUNTY'S EMERGENCY MANAGERS. ON
WE ALSO HAVE BEEN TRACKING WHAT
THEY'RE DOING AND HARDENING
THEIR SYSTEMS. THERE HAVE BEEN
SEVERAL PROPOSALS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE IN TERMS OF
PRIORITIZING THE HARDENING OF
CERTAIN SUBSTATIONS ARE
PRIORITIZING IN TERMS OF
TRANSMISSION AND DISTRIBUTION
SYSTEMS. MOST OF THE BACK UP
THAT THEY WILL BE HAVING- THIS
COMING WELFARE SEASON WILL BE
AT DIESEL GENERATION AND IT
WILL BE TEMPORARY. THEY ARE
PLANNING LONGER TERM TO HAVE-
RENEWABLE. BACKUP GENERATION-
AND IN MY GRADES BUT THAT IS
GOING TO TAKE A BIT LONGER. AND
WE I AS I SAID I WAS VERY
CONCERNED UNTIL MARCH BUT I DO
BELIEVE IN THE CASE OF. ON PGA
ANY THEY HAVE QUICKER. BEAR
PREP. ANYWAY OR WHETHER STATE
HAVE MORE AIRCRAFT THAT WILL
GETTING TO YES YES BOTH BEFORE
AND AFTER THEY HAVE. ALSO ADDED
CAMERAS TO THEIR SYSTEM THEY'VE
ADDED SOME MORE ANALYTICAL
ABILITIES SIMILAR TO SAN DIEGO
GAS ELECTRIC IN TERMS OF
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE
PREDICTIVE NATURE OF FIRES AND-
WEATHER IS. SO THAT IS A
HELPFUL ALL THREE OF THE I. O.
U.'S WILL BE DOING EXERCISES
WITH THE WORLD AND ALL THE
LOCAL AND COUNTIES AND TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS. IN JUNE. JULY AND
THEN THE LAST WILL BE AUGUST BY
SAN DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC SO SORRY
TO BE LONG WINDED- THERE'S
ACTUALLY EVEN MORE THAT WE'VE
DONE BUT THAT GIVES YOU SENATOR
A LITTLE BIT OF AN OVERSIGHT
HOW. CRITICALLY WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING AND HAVING OVERSIGHT OF
THE P. S. TS PREPARATIONS. YEAH
THAT THING FOR THAT ANSWER VERY
MUCH LOOKING FORWARD TO HAVING
RENEWABLE ENERGY GENERATORS.
RING A FIRE SEASON I GOT A CALL
FROM AN EIGHTY TWO YEAR OLD
WILL TEAR DOWN VETERAN. WHO'S
ON OXYGEN HAS POWER TURNED OFF
AND ASSEMBLYMAN LACKEY AND I
RENTED A GENERATOR WENT TO HIS
HOUSE AND SET IT UP AND SETTING
UP THESE DIESEL GENERATOR
OUTSIDE WITH FIRES ALL AROUND
IT MAKES IT MAKES ABSOLUTELY NO
SENSE SO. I KNOW WE'VE GOT
WE'RE GOING TO TRANSITION OUT
OF THAT BUT THAT'S GOOD THEY
WERE MOVING THAT DIRECTION. I
ALSO HAVE TO- CCA'S IN MY
DISTRICT. AND THEY HAVE
CONSIDER CONCERNS IN TERMS OR
TRANSPARENCIES FROM FROM THE
AUDIO USE. THIS IS A IS ARGUE
THAT VERY DIFFICULT TO GET ANY
INFORMATION AND OFTEN WHEN THEY
DO THEY DON'T GET IT IN TIME
FOR THE NECESSARY IT ODDITY. IN
THESE ERROR ERRORS IN THEIR
OPINION HAVE SIGNIFICANT HAS
CREATED SIGNIFICANT COST TO ALL
RATEPAYERS SO THE QUESTION IS
WHAT EFFORTS WE TAKE TO
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY OF CALL
GENERAL. SURGICALLY WITHIN THE
CONTEXT OF THE ENERGY RESOURCES
RECOVERY ACCOUNT. THANK YOU
SENATOR YES TO BE USED AS THE
WORKING WITH IT CCA'S FOR
SEVERAL YEARS PROVIDE THEM WITH
MORE ACCESS TO THE UTILITY
CALCULATIONS THAT GO INTO THAT
THE POWER CHARGE. IN DIFFERENCE
THAT ADJUSTMENT OR THE P. C. I.
A. THIS IS THE MECHANISM THAT
IS USED TO MEET THE STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS. THAT THEIR
CUSTOMERS REMAIN WITHIN THE YOU
JUST LOOK AT WHAT THEY DO NOT
SEE THEIR BILLS GO UP. DUE TO
THE CREATION OF A C. C. A. AN
SPCA CUSTOMERS DO NOT PAY COSTS
THAT SHOULD BE PAID FOR THOSE
ARE ESSENTIALLY IN. CITIES I
THINK THE CHALLENGES THAT THE
CALCULATION QUESTION OUR MARKET
SENSITIVE INFORMATION. ARE TO
BE KEPT CONFIDENTIAL I'M FROM
THE ENERGY MARKET PARTICIPANTS.
AND THE CCA'S OUR MARKET
PARTICIPANTS. AND WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE CCA'S TO ALLOW
FOR THEM TO SIGN A NON
DISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS AND HAVE
SELECTED REPRESENTATIVES. HAD
TO DO THAT DATA. THIS IS
CURRENTLY BEING FURTHER
REVIEWED IN THE CURRENT POWER
CHARGE IN DIFFERENT ADJUSTMENT
PROCEEDINGS UNTIL OF THE NAMES
WE GIVE THANKS. BUT THE PC IS
HEADED TO FINDING WAYS TO.
PROVIDE MORE ACCESS TO THIS
THAT THE KEY DATA SURROUNDING
THE- YOU SEE I A AND THE OTHER
MARKET SENSITIVE DATA WHERE
WHERE WHERE THIS ISSUE AND
WORKING WORKING ON ANSWER.
GREAT THANK YOU FOR THAT KIND
OF GOT A FINAL QUESTION. I'M
GONNA ASK YOU A QUESTION I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE ANSWER IS.
I DON'T BELIEVE YOU DO THE TWO
OF US MY GOSH THESE I STILL
HAVEN'T FIGURED OUT HOW TO USE
READERS AND A MASK IT WITHOUT
**** UP MY GLASSES SO I
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT. NO IT'S NOT
QUESTION- I WILL EVENTUALLY
FIGURE THAT PART OUT. SO
CALIFORNIA'S YOU UTILITIES ARE
SPENDING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON
WELFARE MITIGATION MEASURES
WHICH YOU WERE ALREADY LAYING
OUT. WHICH THEY ARE NOT
CURRENTLY AUTHORIZED TO INCLUDE
IN RATES GIVEN THE FACT THAT CO
THAT ON CUSTOMERS IN THE LARGE
EXPENDITURES I OWE YOU. ALREADY
INCURRED HOW DO YOU SEE
BALANCING THE FOR I ARE USED TO
RECOVER WHAT THEY'VE SPENT AT A
TIME WHEN CUSTOMERS MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO AFFORD RATE INCREASES.
THIS IS CRITICAL- ON AND THIS
IS GOING TO BE A CRITICAL TASK
FOR THE P. YOU SEEN NOT ONLY
NOW BUT IN THE NEXT FEW YEARS-
THAT SEAT YOU SEIZE RATE AND
BILL IMPACT FOR CASH SHOW VERY
LARGE PIECES IN CALIFORNIA WE
DON'T TAKE ACT TO REDUCE THE
OVERALL UTILITY COSTS THE MAIN
DRIVER THE RATE INCREASES IN
FACT WILL BE YOU WHILE FIRE
MITIGATION. ON SOME OF AND IT A
PROGRAMS ARE ALL INCREASING THE
COSTS WE'RE LOOKING INTO WE'RE
LOOKING VERY CLOSELY INTO ALL
OF THE- WE ARE. ENERGY DIVISION
IS DOING A VERY THOROUGH REVIEW
OF ALL PROGRAMS TO SEE WHAT A
SUCCESS OF THE PROGRAMS ARE
WHAT IMPACTS THERE HAVE BEEN
POSITIVE NEGATIVE. AND WHAT
RATE INCREASE. I'M AND WHETHER
THAT CAN CAN INDEED BE AND
MEDICAID AND WE HAVE ALSO BEEN
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT- AS YOU
MENTIONED SIR THAT KOBE IN
NINETEEN IMPACTS AND WE HAVE
MOVED OUR- WE HAVE OF MOVED TO
THE CLIMATE CREDIT OFF SENSE.
AND THAT THAT THAT CUSTOMERS
ENJOY- IN THE SUMMER MONTHS- TO
I JUST SORT OF THEIR BILLS
DOWNWARD AT P. JEANNIE AND EVER
SINCE CLIMATE CREDITS- WOULD
HAVE NORMALLY BEEN DISPERSED IN
OCTOBER NAY BEEN MOVED UP. AND
SPLIT- TWO BILLS IN MAY AND
JUNE- AND THEN WE PROPOSED A
DECISION FOR SMALLER UTILITIES
LIBERTY AND OR- OCTOBER
CLAIMING CREDIT APPLY IN JUNE
AND JULY. SO THOSE ARE SOME
SOME SMALL AREAS OF HORTON
EVERY DOLLAR COUNTS
PARTICULARLY IT ALWAYS
PARTICULARLY NOW AND WE'RE
EXPERIENCING THE DIFFICULTIES
OF KOBE NINE. NINE IT IS AN
ONGOING. WITH WHAT MEDICAID
CLASS WE REALLY HAVE TO BE
EXTRAORDINARILY CAREFUL AND
THOUGHTFUL. ABOUT THE- THE RATE
RECOVERY THAT THE I- USE ARE
ARE ABLE TO HOUSE. GREAT RIGHT
SHARE YOUR ANSWER AGAIN PRESHOW
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO SERVE AND
LOOK LOOKING FOR TO SPEAK YOUR
CONFIRMATION. MAKES THE MOTION.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU MISTER
VICE CHAIRMAN THE SENATOR MINE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IN. GOOD
AFTERNOON PRESIDENT BACK SURE I
WANTED TO START BY. OFFERING MY
CONGRATULATIONS AS WELL NOT
ONLY ON YOUR APPOINTMENT ANA AS
PRESIDENT THE P. C. BUT TO
THANK YOU FOR YEAR. YEARS OF
SERVICE BOTH IN GOVERNMENT IN
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR WE'RE
LUCKY TO HAVE YOU. ON LEAVE THE
PCS OFFICIALLY NOW WITH THE
MANY ISSUES WE'RE DISCUSSING.
OF P. JEANNIE BANKRUPTCY FIRE
IS ITS SENTRA. THE UNITED HAVE
A CHANCE TO SPEAK YESTERDAY AND
I APPRECIATED THAT OPPORTUNITY
I DID WANT TO RAISE FROM MY
COLLEAGUES- AS YOU KNOW I HAVE.
DIABLO CANYON IN MY DISTRICT IN
SAN LUIS OBISPO COUNTY IT'S
GOING THROUGH A DE
COMMISSIONING. LAND DE
COMMISSIONING AND THE WILD
PRIMARY JURISDICTION IS WITH
THE NRC THE FEDERAL- NUCLEAR
REGULATORY COMMISSION. THE PC
DOES HAVE CERTAIN OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITIES AND AUTHORITY.
AND I WAS JUST HOPING YOU COULD
SHARE WITH ME AND COLLEAGUES
AND OTHERS- KIND OF YOUR VIEW
AND PARTICULARLY NOW WITH COOL
BUT NINETEEN THE LOCAL CONCERN.
IS SAFETY SAFETY SAY HE- THAT
MAY REVISE INCLUDES AN ADDED
TUITION FOR THE P. YOU SEE.
DEDICATED TO OVERSIGHT OF THE
DECOMMISSIONING PROCESS AND WE
JUST APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENT
TOM. WHAT PRIORITY THIS IS FOR
YOU- THE P. YOU SEE AND IF
THERE'S ANY PARTICULAR CONCERNS
WITH COVERT NINETEEN AND- SOME
OF THAT WORK FORCE WORKING FROM
HOME AND NOT AT THE PLANT. IS
SENATOR AND WE DID HAVE A VERY
NICE VISIT YESTERDAY AND I
APPRECIATED THAT GREATLY. AS AS
YOU WELL STATE AND- THE HE
JENNY ARM SHUT DOWN OF REACTOR
ONE WILL OCCUR IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY SKEWS ME TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR AND REACTOR TO AND TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. AND AS YOU WELL
KNOW TO THE P. GINNY REPAIRS
HAVE BEEN FUNDING AND THE
DECOMMISSIONED TRUST FUND TO
COVER THE COST OF THE
DECOMMISSIONING FACILITY. THE
ACTUAL PROCESS AS YOU NOTED OF
THE DE COMMISSIONING IS
OVERSEEN BY THE NUCLEAR
REGULATORY COMMISSION- BUT THE
P. JEANNIE AND HAS PROVIDED
TIMELY AS IN THAT DO YOU. THE
COMMISSION FILINGS TO THE PC.
ON DE IT I'LL JUST STEP ASIDE
FOR A SECOND THE CODE RED
NINETEEN I'M NOT MY MUST AND
NOT PERSONALLY AWARE RIGHT NOW
OF HOW- DIAVEL IS WORKING WITH
THEIR WORK FORCE OBVIOUSLY FOR
SAFETY REASONS AND NUCLEAR
POWER PLANT MUST HAVE. PEOPLE
ON SITE TO HAVE IT OPERATING
PROPERLY SO- HOWEVER- THE- THEY
THE WORK FORCE IN IN THE
AGREEMENT WILL CERTAINLY BE
TAKEN CARE OF THROUGH THE
DECOMMISSIONING PROCESS. AND
UNDER THE TIME LINES AND AS YOU
KNOW SIR THAT THE LAST OF THE
BUILDINGS IN THE ANTIQUE
STRUCTURAL. WILL BE REMOTE JAN
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE SO THIS IS A
LENGTHY PROCESS I MEAN THE
SPENT FUEL- MY MAIN STORED ON
SITE. UNTIL TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN
THAT'S OF COURSE IS IF THE
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY HAS
PERMANENT- STORAGE FACILITY BY
THAT TIME BEING A NATIVE OF
THAT AND I'VE FOR IT NOT TO BE
YUCCA MOUNTAIN JUST HAVE TO SAY.
ANY RATE. I IT IS IT IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO US AS
YOU NOTED WE DO HAVE ONE
POSITION THAT WE HAVE RECEIVED
IN THE AND THE BUDGET BUT FOR
AT ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE-POSITION THAT WILL BE
OVERSEEING THE- DECOMMISSIONING
EFFORTS AS AS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY IN THAT IS I
THINK YOU ALSO- WERE ENQUIRING.
SENATOR ABOUT THE LAND AND
NOTHING AROUND I AM HELLO AND
NOTHING REGARDING THE TREATMENT
OF LANCE'S THEN DETERMINE. AT
THIS TIME- IN THE DAY OUT LOCAL
CANYON RETIREMENT DECISION P.
GENIE IS REQUIRED TO COME BACK
TO THE PC. IF THEY EVER HAVE
ANY PLANS TO DO ANYTHING WITH
THOSE LANDS. SO I WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT I MENTIONED THAT
TO YOU AND I'M MORE THAN HAPPY
TO STAY CLOSE TO YOUR STAFF.
AND YOU- TO KEEP YOU INFORMED
OF THOSE THINGS GREAT WELL I
APPRECIATE THAT AND
PARTICULARLY THE- RECOGNITION
OF THE PC OVERSIGHT OVER ANY.
DISPOSITION OF SURROUNDING
LANDS AS YOU POINTED OUT WHEN.
WHEN DIABLO CANYON WAS
ORIGINALLY LICENSED IT WAS
LICENSED WITH THE UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE SPENT RODS WOULD BE
EXPORTED FROM THE AREA. AND
WITHOUT KNOWLEDGE OF THE
EARTHQUAKE FAULTS THAT HAVE
SINCE BEEN DISCOVERED. AND SO
PART OF THE DE COMMISSIONING
DECISION. WAS BASED ON THE
SEISMIC CHALLENGES FACING. THE
OUTLOOK CANYON- AND THERE'S NO
PROSPECT AT THIS POINT OF THE
SPENT RODS GOING ANYWHERE THEIR
STORTING CASKS ON THE SITE AND
SO THE SAFETY CONCERNS OF THE
COMMUNITY. WILL CONTINUE FAR
BEYOND THE ACTUAL
DECOMMISSIONING OF THE REACTOR
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
SENSITIVITY TO THAT IN YOUR-
STAFF'S OVERSIGHT- AND AGAIN WE
ALSO DISCUSSED THE IMPORTANCE
OF TRANSPARENCY IN THE PUBLIC
PROCESSES WE DID HAVE A P. UC.
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE
CONVENE IN A HEARING. IN SAN
LUIS OBISPO RELATED TO ONE OF
MY PIECES OF LEGISLATION
STUDYING ECONOMIC IMPACTS AND
THAT WAS WELL ORGANIZED IN
PROVIDED. BOTH NOTICE IN STRONG
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION SO WANTED
KNOWLEDGE THAT MAN MAN IN
CHARGE HAVE A FINAL QUESTION
AND- RESIDENT BATCH I DID NOT I
APOLOGIZE I DIDN'T RAISE THIS
WITH YOU YESTERDAY. AND I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU'LL BE ABLE TO
ANSWER BUT YOU COULD MAYBE TAKE
THIS QUESTION UNDER SUBMISSION-
IF YOU DON'T HAVE AN IMMEDIATE
RESPONSE BUT- IT'S BEEN BROUGHT
TO MY ATTENTION THAT SOME OF
THE RATE. PAYER FUNDED ENERGY
EFFICIENCY MONIES- REPORTEDLY
AMOUNTING TO ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
EIGHTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDS. THAT HAVE NOT YET BEEN
ALLOCATED- COULD YOU COMMENT ON
THIS AND THE STATUS AS TO THE
STATUS OF THOSE FUNDS AND AGAIN
I REALIZE I DIDN'T BREAK WITH
ESTHER AND IF IT'S NOT A- SO I
WOULD WELCOME. THEIR RESPONSE
AT YOUR CONVENIENCE. CENTER I
AM FAMILIAR WITH WITH IT BUT I
DON'T WANT TO- GIVE YOU
MISINFORMATION SO IF I MAY I
WENT I'D LIKE TO TAKE THAT THAT
QUESTION BACK TO STAFF AND GET
BACK TO YOU AND THE COMMITTEE
REGARDING THAT QUESTION THANK
YOU GOOD AND I APPRECIATE THAT
AND I WILL LOOK FORWARD TO.
HEARING BACK FROM YOU WANT THAT
INFORMATION IS OBTAINED IN WITH
THAT I TO LOOK FORWARD TO.
CASTING A STRONG VOTE IN
SUPPORT. OF YOUR CONFIRMATION
AN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU SENATOR RUNNING- I WILL A
SAY HOW MUCH I APPRECIATE ALL
OF MY COLLEAGUES ASK AND- THE
MOST SERIOUS QUESTIONS IT'S
ALWAYS GOOD TO GO LAST. I
HOWEVER I DO WANT TO ADD- TO
WHAT SENATOR MONNING SAID I HE
TALKED ABOUT- DIABLO CANYON AND
I OF COURSE WOULD BE REMISS NOT
TO BRING UP SANTA NO FREE AND
SAN DIEGO COUNTY SOMETHING I
KNOW THAT SENATOR BATES ALSO-
GIVEN THE PROXIMITY- WOULD
PROBABLY AGREE THAT ANY.
OVERSIGHT AND MONITORING THAT
WE ARE ABLE TO HAVE AT THE
STATE LEVEL RECOGNIZING THAT
IT'S REAL THE FEDERAL ENERGY.
COMMISSION'S RESPONSIBILITY BUT
WE HAD A SIMILAR SITUATION OF
SPENT FOR FUEL RODS BEING STORE
OUT ON THE COAST AND
COMMUNITIES CONCERN SO I WILL.
THAT PUBLIC. BUT KNOWING THAT
YOU ARE COMPLETELY OF THAT
PRESENT BADGER. I'M THIS IS A
INCREDIBLE OF IMPORTANT UP SO
HIGH HAVE ONE MAYBE TWO
QUESTIONS AND IT HAS TO DO
WITH- THE PGA ANY BANKRUPTCY
AND I RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE
SENSITIVITIES AROUND THAT
ISSUE. BUT YOUR THOUGHTS
GENERALLY I WANT TIME GIVEN THE
AMOUNT OF DEBT THAT P. JEANNIE
WILL HAVE COMING OUT OF
BANKRUPTCY. YOUR THOUGHTS IN
TERMS OF- WILL WE BE IN DANGER
OR WILL THEY BE IN DANGER OF
DEFAULTING IN THE EVENT IT WAS
DENIED ACCESS TO EITHER AB TEN
FIFTY FOUR WILDFIRE FUND. OR
COST RECOVERY- IF ANOTHER
MASSIVE FIRE IT'S SORT OF A
BROAD QUESTION OF WHAT YOUR
THOUGHTS ARE ABOUT THIS
PROCESS. AND ALSO MAYBE AT THE
SAME TIME ALL ASK ABOUT YOUR
THOUGHTS I TO SHARE YOUR
THOUGHTS ABOUT PROTECTING WRITE
PAPERS AND ENSURING. PROPER
OVERSIGHT AND NONPROFIT
CORPORATION IF THAT IS THE PLAN
B. E. R. THAT MOVES FORWARD
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION- AS A
NONPROFIT CORPORATION THEY
WOULD BE EXEMPT FROM C. WOULD
THEY BE EXEMPT FROM CPUC
JURISDICTION ANY THOUGHTS ON.
HOW THE LEGISLATURE COULD
INSURE RATE PAYERS ARE PROPERLY
PROTECTED SO KIND OF A- HUGE
QUESTION WITH BUDGET COMPONENTS
BUT YOUR THOUGHTS I WOULD
GREATLY APPRECIATE. PRESIDENT
BADGER. WELL ON THE LAWYERS
HAVE TOLD ME I HAVE TO SAY THE
FOLLOWING. A PROPOSED DECISION
FROM THE ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
JUDGE WAS ISSUED ON APRIL
TWENTIETH TWENTY TWENTY AND IS
SCHEDULED TO BE VOTED ON BY THE
COMMISSION TOMORROW WELL I CAN
DESCRIBE THE ELEMENTS AND THE
PROPOSED DECISION WHICH I'M
HAPPY TO DO. THIS MATTER IS
STILL UNDER CONSIDERATION AT
THE COMMISSION AND I CAN NOT
PREJUDICE THE RESULT OF THE
DELIBERATION THAT IS STILL
OCCURRING. SO HAPPY TO WALK
THROUGH THE ELEMENTS OF THE
PROPOSED DECISION IF THAT WOULD
BE HELPFUL ON. I THINK THAT
UNDER OBVIOUSLY STATUTE TEN
FIFTY FOUR OUR- JOB OUR
RESPONSIBILITY WAS TO WORK TO
ENSURE THAT P. JEANNIE HAD. AN
AVENUE OUT OF BANKRUPTCY BY
JUNE THIRTY AND WITH OUR VOTE
TOMORROW WE WILL HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED THAT. I WILL SAY
IF I MAY JUST. THERE ARE FOR
ONE SECOND THAT PROCEEDING WAS-
STARTED IN OCTOBER. AND THE PC
OFTEN HIS CRITICIZED FOR NOT
BEING ABLE TO BE NIMBLE AND NOT
BEING ABLE TO WORK QUICKLY. AND
PROCEEDINGS SUPPOSEDLY ARE
ALWAYS GOING TO TAKE EIGHTEEN
MONTHS WELL IN SEVEN MONTHS
WE'VE COMPLETED A VERY
COMPLICATED. AND DIFFICULT TASK
AND- I LOOK FORWARD TO OUR
DISCUSSION TOMORROW AND TAKING
ALL THE PUBLIC COMMENT THAT WE
WILL RECEIVE AND THEN VOTING ON
THE DECISION. HAVING SAID THAT.
RIGHT THE PRESUMPTION IS THAT
THEY WILL COME OUT OF
BANKRUPTCY IN JUNE ON JUNE
THIRTIETH. ACTION IS THAT THAT
IN SO DOING THEY WILL BE
PROPERLY. AT FINANCED I DON'T
THINK I SHOULD GO ANY FURTHER
INTO SOME OF THE DETAILS- MADAM
PRO TEM- BECAUSE I WOULD BE
SPECULATING BEFORE THE DECISION
I. SO DOES THAT NO I TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND I APPRECIATE YOUR OB.
YOUR RESPONSE AND ALSO I THINK
THESE ARE THE BIG ISSUES ALL OF
US ARE ACTUALLY THINKING ABOUT
IN TERMS OF AS WE COME OUT OF
AS AS THEY COME OUT OF
BANKRUPTCY HOW CAN A BALLOT SO
MANY OTHER ISSUES IN ORDER TO
BE BACK SAME POSITION SO. AND
GIVEN THAT I HAVE SEVERAL
ATTORNEYS ON THIS COMMITTEE
IDEA I CAN APPRECIATE THE
ADVICE OF GOOD COUNSEL. THAT
HAS TO GO THROUGH THE ELEMENTS
OF THE PROPOSED DECISION IT IF
YOU MADAM PRO TEM OR ANY OF THE
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TO LIKE TO
HAVE ME DO THAT. I DON'T THINK
I DON'T THINK I NEED TO DO THAT
I I'VE CERTAINLY LOOKED AT IT I
WILL CORRECT I THINK I THINK I
MISSPOKE AND SAID THE ENERGY
COMMISSION BEFORE I MET THE
NUCLEAR REGULATORY AS IT
RELATED TO SEE AN ENDO FREE-
BUT I'M I'M- THERE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ASKED ABOUT PLAN B. F.
WHAT IS REFERRED TO AS PLAN B.
AND THAT'S- LEGISLATION OF
COURSE THAT IS THE FOR YOU ALL-
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS- WORKED
VERY HARD ON. AND ON IT IS.
CONSIDERED THAT PLAN B. PLAN A
IS WHAT WE REALLY HOPE HAPPENS
AND THAT IS THAT YOU HAVE A
HEALTHY- INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITY. THAT IS ABLE TO-
SUPPLY RELIABLE SAFE. AND CLEAN
ENERGY FOR THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE IN THE TERRITORY. THAT
P. JEANNIE COVERS ON. BUT I.
THE IT ASK LAND BE IS WRITTEN
REFER TO AS AS SB THREE FIFTY
ON NEED TO SEE WHAT INDEED
HAVE- AS- AUTHORITY AND
OVERSIGHT AND WOULD HAVE TO
APPROVE- CERTAIN THINGS WITH
IN- WITH IN THE- GOLDEN. GOLDEN
STATE ENERGY- ENTITY ARE IT
GIVES US OVERSIGHT AUTHORITY
AND- COVERS HOW RATES WILL BE
SAT ON FOR THE GOLDEN STATE
ENERGY AND IT REQUIRES THAT THE
CQC WOULD DISPOSE OF ANY GOLDEN
STATE ENERGY APPLICATIONS TO
ISSUE DEBT WITH THAT HUNDRED
DAYS OF TAKEOVER. CONGRESS
TRIGGERED BY THE BANKRUPT
OFFRAMP AND- IN THE PROPOSED
DECISION YOU WILL KNOW THAT- WE
HAVE A SIX STEP ON ENFORCEMENT
SERIES THAT ARM WOULD LEAD TO
THE ULTIMATE REAP REVOCATION OF
THE- CERTIFICATE OF PUBLIC
CONVENIENCE AND NECESSITY.
WHICH WOULD THEN GO TO AN OFF
RAMP LEADING TO BRANDY SO YES
WE WILL HAVE OVERSIGHT AND OFF
OBVIOUSLY. YOU YOU DON'T HAVE
WOULD NOT HAVE STATE YOU WOULD
NOT HAVE SHAREHOLDERS SO THERE
WOULD NOT BE- AWAY TO HAVE
COSTS HE- INCURRED BY
SHAREHOLDERS AS OPPOSED TO RATE
PAYERS AND IN THIS STATE THE
STATE IN THIS CASE STATE. I'M
NOT SURE DID THAT COVER YOU
QUESTIONS. IT DOES I THINK I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO SEE THINGS
UNFOLD GOING FORWARD WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE ALL KINDS OF
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT. WHAT THAT
WILL LOOK LIKE AND OF COURSE AS
WE KNOW WE CAN ALWAYS. GAGE
WHAT- WHAT COULD IMPACT- THAT
WE HAVE NO CONTROL OVER- THE
CLIMATE IBERS ECCENTRIC BUT-
THANK YOU PRESIDENT BADGER- I
THINK UNLESS THERE ARE NO OTHER
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES WE
WILL MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT-
FROM WITNESSES- TAKE TESTIMONY
FROM WITNESSES. AND WE WILL
START WITH WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND WE WILL BEGIN HERE IN ROOM
THREE ONE NINETY ONE. I WANT I
INVITE- WITNESSES FOR I WANT TO
GIVE A LITTLE DIRECTION TO
ENSURE OUR SOCIAL DISTANCE
PLEASE DO NOT FORM A LINE
PERSON AT A TIME TO COME UP TO
THE MICROPHONE. ONCE THAT
SPEAKER CAN CAUSE THE NEXT
WITNESS MAKE UP WORK TO THE MY-
WITH THAT LET ME IN IT. I AM
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFIED COME FORWARD. AND IF
YOU WOULD STATE YOUR NAME AND
WHAT ORGANIZATION IF ANY YOU
ARE WITH AND YOUR POSITION
WELCOME THANK YOU MY NAME IS
KATHERINE BRANDENBURG CAN I
REPRESENT CINEMA CLEAN POWER.
WE AND- HIGHLY SUPPORTIVE OF
AND MAYOR BILL BACK TO SENATE
CONFIRMATION AND ON A PERSONAL
LEVEL I. WANT TO GET MY SHOUT
OUT TO MARIBEL ALSO ADD I'VE
WORKED WITH HER FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS AND MANY DIFFERENT
CAPACITIES AND CALIFORNIA'S
VERY LUCKY TO HAVE HER. THANK
YOU FOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE. OKAY SEEING NO ONE
ELSE HERE I CAN WE CHECK IN ON
ROOM ONE TWELVE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE THAT NEEDS TO TESTIFY
WOULD LIKE TO COME FORWARD AND
SUPPORT. OKAY SEEING NO ONE
THERE- WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WHO WILL
BE TESTIFYING VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS- WE WILL
HAVE A MODERATOR- IF YOU WULD
PLEASE PROP THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TEST. I IN SUPPORT
OF PRESIDENT BOETTCHER. AND WE
WILL BEGIN. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE JOINING US
BY PHONE AND YOU WERE IN
SUPPORT YOU MAY GET INTO THE
QUEUE BY PRESSING ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. IF
YOU ARE USING A SPEAKER PHONE
PLEASE PICK UP THE HANDSET
BEFORE PRESSING THE NUMBERS
AGAIN ON THE PHONES IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO THANK YOU WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER TWENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD LOW NUMBER. TWO SIX.
AND YOUR HANDS WE WERE CELLULAR
AND PLEASE ON LAYING HERE TODAY
ON BHALF OF ADVANCED ENERGY
ECONOMY. WE ARE A TRADE GROUP
MADE UP OF COMPANIES DEDICATED
TO CLEAN AFFORDABLE ENERGY- AND
WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT-
PRESIDENT DOCTORS APPOINTMENT
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM MODERATOR NEXT
WITNESS. WE GO TO MY NUMBER
TWENTY SEVEN LINE TO SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK. IN MY
TWENTY SEVEN YOU MAY WANT TO
CHECK YOUR MUTE FEATURE WE DO
HAVE THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU.
CABLE MOVE ON TO MY NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR THAT IS WHY NUMBER
TWO FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS O
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
LILLIAN MRS AND I AM A SENIOR
MANAGER OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
AT THE CENTER FOR SUSTAINABLE
ENERGY. I AM PLEASED TO PROVIDE
OUR YEAH I THINK THE QUIRK FOR
THE CONFIRMATION OF PRESIDENT
FACTOR I THINK COMMISSIONER.
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES AND-
THE BACHELOR AT HIGHS AND THE
BACKGROUND IN MANAGING COMPLEX
AGENCIES AND ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS THE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SECTORS. AND SHE COMMITTED TO
CIVIL SERVANTS AND FOCUSED ON
CREATING OPERATIONAL EFFICIENCY
IT'S WHICH IS ESPECIALLY
CRITICAL AT THE UNDER WILD CARD.
I WE AGAIN WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE PERMISSION OF PRESIDENT
ACTOR AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER THIRTY FIVE
CENTS LINE NUMBERS THREE FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
THIS IS SCOTT WEDGE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COALITION OF
UTILITY EMPLOYEES THE STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS. THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PIPE TRADES COUNCIL AND THE
WESTERN STATES COUNCIL SHEET
METAL WORKERS- IT IS YES ECKLEY
HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT PRESIDENT
BADGER WHO HAS A LONG HISTORY
OF COLLABORATING WITH ORGANIZED
LABOR AND WE TRUST HER AND WE
LOOK FORWARD. TO WORKING WITH
HER AT THE COMMISSION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT AWARENESS YET I WE HAVE
ONE NUMBER FORTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE FOR ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM COACHELLA
MEMBERS ARE NEW MELONES
REPRESENTING THE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND DEMAND
MANAGEMENT COUNCIL ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF PRESIDENT PATRICK WE
APPRECIATE HER LONG AND
SUCCESSFUL HISTORY ON IMPROVING
THE ADMINISTRATION PROGRAMS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU YOU HAVE
LINE NUMBER FOURTEEN THAT IS
LINE ONE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A BETTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS TO COMMITTEES
THIS IS CHANCE MIGHT BE JONES
WITH THE INDEPENDENT ENERGY
PRODUCERS. WHICH SUPPORTS THE
CONFIRMATION OF DISPATCHER AS
PRESIDENT OF THE P. AND SHE-
SHE ASSUMED- THAT ROLE
UNPRECEDENTED CHALLENGES THAT
THE NOTED- INCLUDING HOW
DESTRUCTIVE FIRES. SEE AN PSP
AS ALL THIS WHILE THE ISSUES
ALSO CONFIDED PGD APART BE PC
WHICH IS REQUIRED TO ADDRESS
THINGS SUCH AS THE INTEGRATED
RESOURCE PLANNING. OTHER
PROCEEDINGS DECIDED YOU'RE
CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE AS WELL AS
AT THE STRUCTURE SIXTY- MISS
BADGER. BADGER HAS- AT THE
STEADY HOW MUCH DO YOU SEE AND
WE ARE MAKING PROGRESS ON ALL
FRONTS- WELL HONED SKILLS AND-
GOVERNMENT SERVICE- AND SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WELL
WE WOULD URGE YOU TO COME FROM
HER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS THANK YOU WE GO TO LINE
A LINE THIRTY SIX THAT PLANE
THREE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY MY NAME IS HASSAN A
CROWD ON THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF SANDBAGS THE SAN DIEGO
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS. AND
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITY
COMMISSIONS ONE OF THE MOST
INFLUENTIAL REGULATORY AGENCIES
AND THE YOU ARE. MANY OF THE
SERVICES AND IN THIS IS THAT
THE COMMISSION OVERSEES
INTERSECT WITH SANDBAGS ROLE AS
THE METROPOLITAN PLANNING
ORGANIZATION ON REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING AGENCY
FOR THE SAN DIEGO REGION.
INCLUDING TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES AVAIL SAFETY AND
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK
COMPANIES. I HAVE THE PLEASURE
OF MEETING WITH PRESIDENT
BUDGET LAST YEAR TO DISCUSS
MANY OF THESE ISSUES AND I
APPRECIATE THAT OPENNESS. TO
HEAR FROM STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT
HOW THIS THE STATE COUNCIL OR
THE WORK WE ARE DOING TOGETHER.
TO HELP THE STATE MEET ITS
GOALS FOR ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE CLIMATE
CHANGE AND HAD A QUALITY. THAT
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO PARTNER PRESENT ON THE
COMMISSION ON THESE ISSUES AND
I SUPPORT PRESIDENT BY THEIR
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS. WE
GO TO LINE NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT
THAT IS LINE TWO EIGHT TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME'S BACK FINE
I'M EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE CHOICE
ASSOCIATION- THAT THERE ARE NOW
TWENTY ONE CAN YOU CHOICE
AGGREGATORS SERVING ENERGY
NEEDS OF MORE THAN TEN MILLION
CUSTOMERS. MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE THAN
CHARACTER CALIFORNIA- THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE CONFIRMATION OF
PRESIDENT DOCTOR TODAY. AND WE
DO LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
HER- AND THE REST OF THE
COMMISSION ON MANY OF THESE
IMPORTANT ISSUES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THE
LINE NUMBER THIRTY THREE THAT
FLYING THREE THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MAYOR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS CASSANDRA TALK WITH CALPINE
CORPORATION. ONE OF THE STATE'S
LARGEST INDEPENDENT POWER
PRODUCERS- I'M CALLING IN AS
SUPPORT- OTHER THAN BATCH OF
CONFIRMATION- AND ALSO AS ON A
PERSONAL LEVEL AS A BOARD
MEMBER OF CALIFORNIA WHEN THE
LEAD WHICH IS A NON PORT PART
OF AN ORGANIZATION. THAT
SUPPORTS TRAIN CAN PROMOTE
WOMEN IN TWO. POINT EIGHT
OFFICE MORE ABOUT IF HE AND THE
STAR ALL THAT WE REPRESENT- SO.
HAPPY TO BE HERE OR ACTUALLY
NOT HERE BUT ON THE PHONE
SUPPORT- HEARD NOMINATION AND-
AND SERVICE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. GOOD MY NUMBER FORTY
THREE THAT'S LINE FOR THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM PREPARE ME THIS IS MARK
FENSTER MAKER ON BEHALF OF
PENINSULA CLEAN ENERGY A JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY. OF ALL THE
COUNTY SAN MATTEO AND ALL
TWENTY OF IT CITIES AND WE'RE
RUNNING A COMMUNITY TOWARDS
AGGREGATOR PROGRAM. WE ARE IN
TWO YEAH SIX SUPPORT OF MERRILL
BASHER IT'S QUITE EVIDENT WHY
THE GOVERNOR APPOINTED HER TO
LEAD THE CPUC GIVING AWAY SHE'S
BUYING ALL OF THE DIFFERENT
CRISES FACING THE STATE
CURRENTLY. THANK YOU IN
REGARDS- CONFIRMATION OF TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
WITNESS. BUT A LINE NUMBER
TWENTY SEVEN THAT'S LINE TWO
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN'T
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MARK COUNTY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF TURN THE UTILITY REFORM
NETWORK. WHICH STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE CONFIRMATION OF
PRESIDENT THATCHER BECAUSE OF
HER LEADERSHIP COMMITMENT TO
THE PUBLIC INTEREST. THE WAY IS
THAT WHEN THERE WAS THE SHELTER
AT HOME ORDER- HER LEADERSHIP
HELP. ME CLEAN MOVED TO VERY
CALL PROCEEDINGS AND CONTINUE
THE IMPORTANT WORK THE FACT
THAT SHE HAD STARTED- INTO
RESTRICTED VISION THAT THE
FIFTEENTH WE HAVE BECOME MUCH
MORE EFFECTIVE IN MAKING
DECISIONS AND RUNNING PER
FEEDING. AND WE'RE VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT AND BELIEVE SHE HAD THE
RIGHT LEADER AT THE RIGHT TIME
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
TONY- MADAME MODERATOR OTHERS
WITNESSES. I LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SHOW SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. HOW WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME
PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- MADAME MODERATOR AND WE
WILL NOW ODD TURN. TO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION AND FOLLOW THE
SAME ORDER LET ME JUST THANK
EVERYONE PEOPLE ARE SPEAKING
VERY CLEARLY VERY SLOWLY- AND I
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH LET
ME START- IF THERE ARE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN
OPPOSITION WE WILL START HERE
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE.
IF THERE'S ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME FORWARD. SEEING NO
ONE ARE I BELIEVE WE HAVE NO
ONE IN OUR ROOM ONE TWELVE SO
MANTA MODERATOR WE WILL COME
BACK TO YOU FOR THE-
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE. WILL
YOU PLEASE PROP INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE APPOINTMENT.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. IF YOU ARE USING A
SPEAKER PHONE PLEASE PICK UP
THE HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING THE
NUMBERS AGAIN AT THIS TIME IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SEE WHAT IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN IS
ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEY PAD.
THANK YOU- MAN MODERATOR ARE
YOU ABLE TO GIVE ME THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE- WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. I HAVE NO ONE IN
MY QUEUE AT THIS TIME. OKAY
LET'S GIVE IT A SECOND. MADAME
MODERATOR IF YOU'LL CHECK THE
LAWN ONE LAST TIME TO BE SURE
THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM EVERYONE.
AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO GET INTO
THE QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEY PAD AT THIS TIME. AND I
HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
MATAMATA WRITER THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR ASSISTANCE- I
WILL BRING THE CONVERSATION
BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
SENATE. MOVIE CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH AND IF I
COULD- JUST SAY. IS IT BETTER
WE I WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF MY COLLEAGUES AND A COUPLE
OF THE SPEAKERS WE ARE VERY
FORTUNATE TO HAVE YOU AT THIS
TIME- GIVEN THE CRITICAL ISSUES
WORKPLACE AND AS A STATE NOT
JUST WITH THIS PAN. BUT WE
ALREADY KNEW WE HAD ISSUES WITH
OUR ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE
NETWORK- I AND I REALLY
APPRECIATED YOUR COMMENTS
RELATED TO THE PROCESS. AND THE
P. T. REALLY WORK INTO. TAKE
APPROPRIATE ACTION WITH ALL
CONSIDERATION IN A MORE- TIMELY
FASHION WE APPRECIATE THAT VERY
MUCH IN THE ROLE THAT YOU PLAY
WITH US AND SO I JUST WANTED TO
SAY THAT BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO
THE VOTE. MADAM SECRETARY WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AND
TO THE SENATORS WOULD ALL MAKE
SURE THE MICROPHONES ARE ON YES.
MONNING NINE RUNNING I'D ROB HI
ROTH AYE WILK ALL RIGHT LOOK I
HAD AYE CAN I ORDER ZERO FOUR
TO ZERO YOU ARE CONFIRMED
CONGRADULATIONS PRESIDENT
BOETTCHER. AND LET ME
ACKNOWLEDGE US SENATOR BATES
WHO IS AT HOME AND EXPRESSED
HER SUPPORT AT THE TIME WHEN I
SHE IS ABLE TO VOTE ON THE
FLOOR COLLEAGUES AND MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WE WILL TAKE A FIVE
MINUTE. BREAK TO ACCOMMODATE-
THOSE WHO NEED TO TAKE A QUICK.
FIVE MINUTE BREAK AND WE WILL
BE RIGHT BACK.
WE WILL- COME
BACK TO ORDER. NEXT UP WE WILL
TAKE UP THE APPOINTMENT OF MR
TOAST ON THE SHOCK IN. THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION. I SEE HIM ON
SCREEN LET ME SAY WELCOME- WE
ARE PLEASED TO MEET YOU
VIRTUALLY. AND IF THERE'S
ANYONE WITH YOU THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE TO INTRODUCE PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO MAKE THOSE
INTRODUCTIONS AND THEN IF YOU
WOULD GO RIGHT INTO YOUR
OPENING COMMENTS. AND THEN WE
WILL MOVE TO MEMBERS FOR
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS THANK
YOU WELCOME. THANK YOU MADAM
TEN CAN YOU HEAR ME CLEARLY WE
CAN'T THANK YOU. OKAY VERY GOOD
VERY GOOD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
PROGRAM AND SENATORS. THANK YOU
FOR CONSIDERING THE
CONFIRMATION OF MY APPOINTMENT
AS DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION. I
WANT TO EXPRESS MY SINCERE
GRATITUDE TO MY WIFE JULIE MY
CHILDREN JEREMIAH ENJOY. FOR
ALWAYS PROVIDING THEIR
UNWAVERING SUPPORT. THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY TO SERVE IN THIS
ROLE IS AN IS AN OPPORTUNITY OF
A LIFETIME. AND TO THAT END
ALRIGHT AND OUR TEAM ARE
DRIVING INNOVATION AT CALTRANS
TO MEET THE TRAVEL NEEDS OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS. WE WILL CONTINUE
TO ENHANCE THE STATE'S ECONOMY
AND CREATE SAY FOR MORE LIVABLE
COMMUNITIES. THE MAJOR
DISRUPTION TO OUR EVERYDAY
LIVES BECAUSE BY THE CURRENT
CRISIS. OF NINETEEN HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY AFFECTED NOT ONLY
HOW WE TRAVEL AT BUT ALSO HOW
MUCH WE DROP. DURING THIS
CRISIS WE CONTINUE TO DELIVER
PROJECTS I MAINTAIN THE STATE'S
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM. WHILE
PRIORITIZING THE SAFETY OF OUR
WORKERS EXPANDING WORK WINDOWS
THAT'S CELEBRATING T. PROJECTS.
WE HAVE LOOSENED RESTRICTIONS
ON FOOD TRUCKS AND REP AT
BREAST STOPS WE ARE RESPONSIBLY
PERMITTING HEAVIER TRUCKS
CARRYING ESSENTIAL SUPPLIES.
AND WE'RE EDUCATING THE PUBLIC
THROUGH A HIGHWAY MESSAGE SO.
LOOKING FORWARD MY TEAM AND I
HAVE FIVE STRATEGIC PRIORITIES.
SAFETY IS OUR TOP PRIORITY. I
AM COMMITTED TO WORKING
ELIMINATING TRAFFIC PATEL. WE
WILL ALSO IMPROVE ALL MODES OF
TRANSPORTATION. WHILE MAKING
HISTORIC INVESTMENTS AND ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVES. WE
WILL DO SO BY PROMOTING
INNOVATION AN INCREASE IN
EFFICIENCY. TO THIS END WE'RE
EXCHANGING IDEAS A NEW
EFFICIENCIES WHAT OUR PEERS.
LASTLY WE'RE INCREASE IN
ENGAGEMENT WHAT OUR PARTNERS
AND COMMUNITIES TO ACHIEVE
EQUITY AND TRANSPORTATION.
GUIDED BY THESE PRIORITIES MY
EXECUTIVE TEAM AND I ARE
COMMITTED TO ACHIEVING SB ONES
FIX IT FIRST PERFORMANCE
REQUIREMENTS. WE DEVELOPED THE
DEPARTMENT'S FIRST EVER PROGRAM
OF PROJECTS BY SPECIFIC ASSET
TARGETS FOR REPAIRING PAVEMENTS.
BRIDGES DRAINAGE AND TECHNOLOGY
SYSTEM. IN CLOSING. I WANT TO
THANK GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM FOR
POINTING ME TO THIS POSITION.
AND MY ITEM PRO TEM O. THAT
THANK YOU AND THE LEADERS ON
THE COMMITTEE. FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. I AM COMMITTED
TO MAKING LONG TERM INVESTMENTS
MADE POSSIBLE BY SB ONE. TO
IT'S FOR ALL I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SO MUCH- I WILL GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND I
WILL START WITH SENATOR BATES.
GO AHEAD SENATOR BATES I AM NOT
UP. IN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN
BOTH SORRY. THEY COULDN'T GET
IT TO WORK THIS TIME ANYWAY I
WAS AGAIN CONGRATULATIONS. OR
YOUR APPOINTMENT AND DIE HAVE A
BIG JOB I THINK MY DISTRICT
KEEPS YOU VERY BUSY OR WILL
KEEP YOU VERY BUSY I THINK
WE'VE ALREADY ENGAGE YOU ON
OUR- MAJOR PROBLEM DOWN THERE
SO. WILL CONTINUE WORKING
FORWARD ON THAT IT REMAINS A
BIG ISSUE THIS OF THE EXTENSION
OF THE ODD TO FORTY ONE STATE
ROUTE TOLL ROAD. AND WE HAVE A
SUNNY I THINK. ISSUE THERE.
PROBABLY MOST COME TO ME AND I
LIKE YOU TO DIRECT OF. TO THAT
CERTAIN ON. TO THE BUT WILL FOR
JOB HE IS THE ROLE OF COUCH.
BOB PARTNERING UP OUR WITH THE
TOLL ROAD AGENTS. AND ARE.
SOMEHOW OR COUNTY TRANSFER TO
OF TO REACH PLAN AGENTS. FIND
OF YOU A- POSITION I THINK WE
WORKED OUT OUT. BUT THAT HAS
BEEN A CONCERN OF. YOU KNOW HER
SHE HAD BEEN TRYING TO CLAN AND
OF. OR SO THEY GOING TO BE OF A
HUGE ISSUE THIS COUNTY AREA
CERTAIN THAT WHEN IT. AS YOU'RE
AN SO OF THE- PERHAPS YOU
CHALLENGES GOING FORWARD. AND I
LOOK FOR TO WITH YOU MISTER
EACH. SHAKEN DID I SAY THAT
RIGHT I WAS. NAME RIGHT I KNOW
THE NEXT YEARS OR- ISSUES THAT
I KNOW THAT A BIG CHALLENGE. I
DO LOW FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU
I JUST TO PUT THAT ON YOUR
RADI BECAUSE THOSE ARE THE
THINGS THAT START TO. MAKE A
VERY. ON THE TRUST ISSUE WITH
TRANSFER. PLANNING DELIVERY
CROTCH. YEAH THE PARTNER. THAT
CALTRANS WAS HAND WITH YOUR
DISCOUNT TRANSFER. OF DURING
THE DELAY OF THE PRODUCTS. THAT
WE'RE ARE HARD FAR FOR WE TAX.
I'VE BEEN REALLY. OVER ARE KIND.
OF COUNTER AND- A REGIONAL. ON
TRYING. PLANNING AGE. SO I KNOW
YOU'RE OUT FOR THAT. BUT I JUST
WANTED TO BRING TEAR TO. AND I
ASKED YOU TO. NOT ABSOLUTE.
QUALITY MYSELF ANYTIME. I MEAN
ONLY GOT JOBS ELECT OFFICIAL
BECAUSE I SCHOOL. IN H. THAT
DOMINATED OUR OUR ERROR AS WERE
IN. AND GIRL. SO THAT'S HI MY
COMMENTS WERE TWO DAYS BUT ALL
WHEN I. ON LITTLE WHICH WILL
SERVE BE THERE OR JUST. YOUR
SHOW. THANK YOU SIR BATES OUT
ALL QUICKLY SAY THAT I'M VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THAT- THE BUT
CHALLENGES IT IN THE ORANGE
COUNTY AREA WHAT- C. T. A. N.
T. C. A. IS ESPECIALLY AS IT
RELATES TO OUR SOME OF THE
TOTALING CONCERNS ABOUT DOWN
DOWN THERE AND WORKING TOGETHER
NO OUR OUR AND LOOK FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF MENTION SOME OF
THE PRIORITIES. WE HAVE. ONE OF
ITS PRIORITIES OF THIS
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT AND
PARTNERSHIP- I BUILDING
PARTNERSHIPS. BUT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH- O. C. T.
A AND T. CA AND- THE LEADERS.
OF THE TRANSPORTATION LEADERS
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL DOWN THERE
TO MAKE SURE. THAT WE GET TO
THE PLACE WE WANT TO GET YOU
OUT AS IT RELATES TO ISSUES
LIKE. ISSUES LIKE TELLING OUR
IT IN AN ORANGE COUNTY THAT
ERROR I THINK TOTALING WILL
CONTINUE TO BE AN IMPORTANT
PART OF HOW WE IMPROVED. OF THE
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK ACROSS
THE STATE. BOB AND SO DO IT
THROUGH A PARTNERSHIP WILL BE
WILL BE CENTRAL A NOT DOING IT
ALONE SO WE WILL CONTINUE
PLAYING. ROLE IN MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE WORKING TOGETHER I'M
AT THE REGIONAL LEVEL LOCAL
LEVEL AND AT THE STATE. THANK
YOU CENTER NEXT. THANK YOU AND
HAVE TOLD ROADS HAVE BEEN
ACTUALLY A BOON NOD TO MOBILITY
NO QUESTION AND THE CHOICE
THAT'S ALWAYS THERE TO TAKE ON
AND NO ONE TOLD ROUTE OR TOLD
ROUTE I THINK WAS ALWAYS
SOMETHING VERY IMPORTANT YOU
PROVIDE TO OUR CONSTITUENTS.
AND I HAVE BEEN ON ON THAT
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY BOARD
FOR EIGHT YEARS I WAS ON THE
TRANSPORTATION OR AGENCY MORE
FOR ABOUT TWENTY YEARS IT WAS
VERY UNFORTUNATE THAT THEY
THERE WAS SO MUCH THIS SECTION
OVER UP ALL THE PROJECTS IN
SOUTH COUNTY SO I KNOW YOU'RE
THERE TO HELP US HEAL THAT YES
BROWN THE EVERY HOUSE JOB. I
THINK. IS WHAT WE WANT TO
ENSURE THE TEACHER. IT IS PROP
MADE PROMISES CAPTION WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT TRYING TO.
AND WE GET OUR PEOPLE BOARD.
AND GOD GOING TO BE THERE FOR
YOU TO WITH YOU I AM SURE THAT.
I'M JUST CALLING ME AND I'LL BE
CALLING ON YOU IT WE'LL I WILL
GET THAT JOB DONE. THANK YOU
CENTER MAKES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR BATES SENATOR
MINING. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND I WANNA OFFER MY
CONGRATULATIONS TO DIRECTOR ON
A SHOCK IN AN I THINK
TENNESSEE'S LOSSES CALIFORNIA'S
GAIN NINE I APPRECIATED THE-
OPPORTUNITY WE HAD TO TALK THE
OTHER DAY AND YOU ANSWERED MANY
OF MY QUESTIONS. I DO WANT TO
FOLLOW UP ON. SOME OF THE
STATUS FOR CALTRANS WITH THE
COVERT NINETEEN CRISIS AND- IF
YOU COULD SHARE WITH THE
COMMITTEE HOW MANY EMPLOYEES
HAVE TESTED POSITIVE- SINCE THE
PANDEMIC. CAME TO CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU CENTER MOURNING THE
END UP THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME-
LAST WEEK TO IT AND ENGAGE ME
AND TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
CONCERNS YOU HAVE WELL AS FAR
AS THE SAFETY OF OUR-
EMPLOYEES- AT AND THE
DEPARTMENT OVERALL. OUR TOTAL
NUMBER AS OF NOW AS OF LAST
WEEK THE LAST COUNT AT THE END
OF LAST WEEK WAS TWENTY TWO
EMPLOYEES. ARE THE HIGHEST
NUMBER WE HAVE IN ANY
PARTICULAR DISTRICTS FIVE. WE
HAVE FIVE- OF EMPLOYEES THAT
HAVE TESTED POSITIVE- AND- IT
IN DISTRICT THREE AND DISTRICT
ALIVE AND THEN THE NUMBER SORT
OF SPREAD OUT ACROSS THE STATE
FROM THERE WE'VE BEEN VERY
FORTUNATE I CALTRANS THAT-
DEPARTMENT ARE SIZE. ON A WHICH
WOULD ROUGHLY TWENTY THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES- ARE WE ONLY HAVE.
YOU KNOW. TWENTY TWO PEOPLE
THAT ARE TESTED POSITIVE THAT
OF SELF DISCLOSED SO I WORK AND
ALSO I THINK IMPORTANT TO
NOTICE THAT FIFTEEN OF THOSE
TWENTY TWO ARE HAVE ACTUALLY.
RETURN TO WORK- ON THEY'VE GONE
GONE BACK TO THEIR DOCTOR IN
CONCERT THEY'VE GONE THROUGH
THE PROCESS AND THE- BEEN
TESTED US AS WELL NEGATIVE FOR
COVER NINETEEN AND THEY'RE
BACK- AT OUR WORK LOOK SO WE'RE
VERY FORTUNATE NOT A CALTRANS
IS A RELIGION IT IS AN
ENCOURAGING NUMBER IS THERE A
TESTING PROTOCOL IN PLACE. FOR
EMPLOYEES OF CALTRANS. WE SEE
CEREMONY WEEK WE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE. THAT STAFF- YOU DO
TEMPERATURE CHECKS AND DO
TESTING OF THEIR OWN IF THEY'RE
NOT FEELING WELL IF THEY'RE
FEELING LIKE THEY THEY MAY BE
COMING DOWN WITH A FEVER OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT BUT THERE'S
NO REQUIREMENT FROM CALTRANS
FOR COLLEGE ARE ARE TO ACTUALLY
TEST- OUR EMPLOYEES BUT WE
STRONGLY RECOMMEND AND
ENCOURAGE STAFF TO UP TO YOU
KNOW TO TEST THEMSELVES. ARM
AND YOU TO YOU KNOW CHECK IN
WITH THEIR THEIR HEALTHCARE
PROVIDER IF THEY'RE NOT FILLING
UP UP TO- UP TO GET HELP THANK
YOU IS THERE IS THERE ANY DUTY
FOR AN EMPLOYEE TO REPORT TO HR
IF. THEY HAVE SYMPTOMS. WERE
HAVE TESTED POSITIVE. THERE'S A
RECALL TO DO SO IT IT'S ONE OF
THOSE THINGS THAT WE- ENCOURAGE
WE STRONGLY ENCOURAGE AND
RECOMMEND THAT IF THE HOUSE.
THAT THEY REPORTED BACK TO US-
YOU KNOW HOPEFULLY THAT THAT
HAS BEEN THE CASE- BUT THOSE.
DOES THAT LOW NUMBER THAT WE
STILL HAVE. AGAIN WORK WE'RE
FORTUNATE THAT THE NUMBER IS AS
LOW AS IT IS NOT THAT THOSE
TWENTY TWO ARE. ANYTHING TO
TAKE LIKELY- BUT WORK WERE
FORTUNATE BUT WE DON'T HAVE A
REQUIREMENT THAT STAFF HAS TO
COME IN. ON IT AND REPORT- TO
US ARE SPECIFICALLY AT AT THE
DEPARTMENT OR CULTURAL. THANK
YOU AND THEN JUST A FINAL
QUESTION ON BID. ANY PROTOCOLS
IN PLACE. IN MAYBE THROUGH
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE UNION
REPRESENTATIVES. SO MUCH OF THE
OUTDOOR WORK NOW IS IN HEAT
AND- WORKERS WHO CAN MAYBE
SOCIALLY DISTANCE IN SOME OF
THE WORK ENVIRONMENTS BUT WHO
ALSO MIGHT RIDE IN. TRUCKS OR
OTHER VEHICLES TOGETHER TO WORK
SITE- WHAT ARE THE PROTOCOLS
BEING FOLLOWED TO PROTECT THOSE
THAT ARE NOT ABLE TO WORK FROM
HOME. THAT SAME MORNING THAT'S
THAT'S IT NOT A QUESTION THAT
ME THAT THAT WAS ONE OF THE
CHALLENGING PART OF THE
TRANSITION THAT WE FIND TO MAKE
BECAUSE- NO THE OFFICE SPACE
YOU CAN TELL PEOPLE TO ROB. YOU
CAN TELL STAFF TO SPREAD OUT.
AND NOT SORT OF GATHER TOGETHER
BUT WHEN YOU'VE GOT. BOB CREWS
THAT ARE THAT ARE ON A WORK
SITE SOMETIMES THEY HAVE TO BE-
IN IN THE SAME. IN THE SAME
PROXIMAL LOCATION- IT BUT WE'VE
WE'VE INSTITUTED SOME CHANGES
WITHIN A PARTNER LIKE SAYING
FOR EXAMPLE. IF YOU'RE HEADED
TO A CONSTRUCTION SITE MAKE
SURE THAT. YOU LIMIT THE NUMBER
OF- PEOPLE IN A IN A CAB IN A
IN A TRUCK VEHICLE SO INSTEAD
OF YOU KNOW TWO OR THREE PEOPLE
YOU KNOW GETTING A TRUCK WE
LIMIT. THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
CAN GET A TRUCK. OUT WE MAKE
SURE THAT BONE CONSTRUCTION
SITES THAT WE STAGGER THE TIMES
THAT PEOPLE TAKE BREAKS WHEN
THEY GET TO A- WHAT WHAT WHEN
IT'S BREAK TIME SO PEOPLE WERE
NOT GATHERING TOGETHER. INTO
ONE LOCATION. AT THE SAME TIME-
WE'VE MADE SURE THAT THERE IS-
THEY DEFINITELY HAVE PP. AND
WE'VE DONE THINGS LIKE THAT
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S-
CONSISTENT CLEAN AND- OR
SANITIZING OF OUR KIDS THE
CONSTRUCTION AREAS AND
GATHERING AREAS THAT I'M STAFF
ARE WILL SOMETIMES OUT SO
THAT'S- THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
MEASURES THAT WE'VE PUT IN
PLACE BUT- SAFETY IS OUR TOP
PRIORITY AS A DEPARTMENT- AND
IT STARTS WITH. HOW WE RUN OUR
DEPARTMENT WITH OUR OWN TEAM
WITH OUR OWN STUFF WE CAN'T
JUST- SAY THIS AND BE FOCUSED
SOLELY ON ON THE PUBLIC IT
STARTS WITH US AND I THINK IF
WE HAVE A- A SAFETY MINDSET OF
SAFETY APPROACH TO HOW WE DO
OUR WORK THAT PLAYS OUT. WHAT
THE RESPONSE WOULD BE WE HAVE
UP WITH THE PUBLIC AS WELL.
WE'VE WE'VE DONE THAT IN THIS
BOOK THANK YOU AND THEN.
ANOTHER COVERT NINETEEN BUT
RELATED TO. SB ONE FUNDING
SOURCES THERE'S LESS GAS LESS
HIGHWAY TRAFFIC AND AS A
RESULT. LESS DEDICATED FUNDING
COMING IN ANTICIPATED FROM SP
ONE HOUSE AT AFFECTING. EITHER
CURRENT PROJECTS OR PROJECTED-
PROJECTS IN TERMS OF- LOWER
THAN ANTICIPATED. HIGHWAY
REPAIR AND CONSTRUCTION MONEY.
THANK YOU THAT IS FOR THE
QUESTIONS SANTA MONICA BECAUSE
THE WAY WE LOOK AT THINGS WITH
AN APARTMENT WE SORT OF DIVIDE
OUR WHICH DIVIDED OUR FOCUS
UNTIL THE NINETEEN TO THE FIRST
PART OF THE QUESTION YOU ACTS
WHICH IS YOU KNOW HOW ARE YOU
HANDLING AND AN AGING DE THE
TEAM OF STAFF YOU HAVE AND ARE
YOU MAINTAINING THEIR THEIR
WELFARE AND SAFETY. AND A
SECOND PART IS WHAT'S OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO THE PUBLIC
AND HOW WE PERFORMING- WITH OUR
WE MAINTAIN OUR PERFORMANCE TO
THE GENERAL. THE GENERAL PUBLIC
I'LL TELL YOU WE HAVE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
PROJECT- ON THE CONSTRUCTION.
OF THE DEPARTMENT AND ONLY. AT
TWENTY FIVE OF THOSE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
PROJECTS- HAVE BEEN- PUSHED
BACK OR DELAYED. BECAUSE OF
BECAUSE OF COVER NINETEEN. AND
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE REVENUE
SOURCE I THINK EVERYONE KNOWS
VERY WELL THAT ARE REVENUE
SOURCE IS A GAS TAX. AND SO FOR.
WHAT WE'VE SEEN AND WE WERE
VERY FORTUNATE AGAIN IN THIS
PLACE VERY FORTUNATE THAT THE
PROJECTIONS THAT WERE SEEN OF
THAT UP THE REVENUE IT'S NOT
GOING TO DROP AS MUCH AS WE
ORIGINALLY WERE ANTICIPATING.
WE SAW TRAFFIC VOLUMES DROP IN
THE STATE BY THAT 35% ROUGHLY
ON THE MAJOR STATE OUT ON THE
STATE HIGHWAY NETWORK- THE
LOCAL NUMBER IS YOU KNOW WE'VE
HAD SOME DEBATE ABOUT WHAT THAT
PERCENTAGE DROP WHAT'S- WE WERE
A LITTLE NERVOUS ABOUT ENOUGH.
WELL 35% DROP IN TRAFFIC WHAT
IS THAT GOING TO MEAN TO OUR
REVENUE. BUT AGAIN WE'RE VERY
FORTUNATE THAT WE ARE IN THAT.
WORK WE'RE IN A GOOD. CASH
POSITION WHAT WE ARE
ANTICIPATING- BASED ON. THE
INFORMATION THAT WE'VE RECEIVED
FROM- THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS THAT WE WILL HAVE A ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLAR. ROB
IN REVENUES OVER THE NEXT OVER
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS- TO THE
TUNE OF WILL CLOSE TO OUR THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION OR YOU
COULD BROWN OFFICE A FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. A YEAR
AND GAS TAX REVENUE DECREASES
OFF FOR- FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. LOW WE ARE NOT SEEN
ANY INPUT IMMEDIATE IMPACT ON
OUR PROJECT DELIVERY NOW THERE
MAY BE SOME IMPACT IN THE NEXT
FISCAL YEAR OR BEYOND- BUT THE
ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
ARE EXPECTED DROP IN TAX
REVENUE IS GOING TO BE
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO- ADDRESS IN DUE TIME. AND
IT'S OUR HOPE THAT- IF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PASSES A
STIMULUS- THE BILL FOR
TRANSPORTATION. AN ADDITIONAL
ONE INMATE OFFSET SOME OF THAT-
ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLAR
DROP IN REVENUE- OVER THE NEXT
FIVE. THANK YOU NAY. FINAL
COMMENT FAMILY- MADAM PRO TEM
YEAH WE HAD A CHANCE TO DISCUSS
THIS BUT- I JUST MENTION SOME
OF THE SAFETY CHALLENGES IN MY
DISTRICT HIGHWAYS ONE. MAJOR
TOURISM. THOROUGHFARE IN THREE
OF MY COUNTIES- AND TWELVE
TOURISM HAS TAPERED DURING
COVERT NINETEEN. IT'S COMING
BACK AS RECENTLY AS THIS PAST
WEEKEND AND I DID MENTION DO
SOME OF THE MAJOR CONGESTION
SITES THAT. WE FEAR OPPOSE THE
THREAT OF A LETHAL. INCIDENT
HAPPENING- NOT A QUESTION OF
WHETHER BUT A QUESTION OF WIND
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU IN YOUR DEPARTMENT.
OFTEN MULTIPLE AGENCIES COUNTY
HIGHWAY PATROL- AND OTHERS
SPACE. IT'S THERE ARE
SITUATIONS WHERE THE ACTION IS
NEEDED NOW. NOT AFTER A TRAGEDY
SO LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU AND YOUR TEAM AS WE MOVE
FORWARD IN. ONE JUST ALSO
MENTION ARE I FELT VERY GOOD
DISCUSSION ABOUT- WILDLIFE
CORRIDORS AS BECOMING PART OF
CALTRANS FORWARD PLANNING NOT
AS AN AFTER THOUGHT OR- TO
INCORPORATE THAT IT'S PART OF
THE- GUIDANCE THAT AGAIN. I FOR
WILDLIFE SAFETY FOR DROP EVER
IN HUMAN SAFETY- WORKING WITH
THE WILDLIFE CORRIDORS IN THE
MAJOR THOROUGHFARE SO AGAIN- I
THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK THESE
QUESTIONS IN. MISTER DIRECTOR
AGAIN CONGRATULATE YOU ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT AND A YEAR COME TO
THE- ACCOUNT. YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR SURVIVED. THANK YOU OF
MADAME PRO TEN-
CONGRATULATIONS- ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT- WE DIDN'T GET THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WHICH ISN'T
VERY MUCH LOOKING FOR TO
NASHVILLE IS AT A TOWN I LIKE A
LOT OF WANTED YOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS ON REYES
RESTAURANTS AND HOCKEY TALKS
BUT WE CAN DO THAT OFF LINE-
ACTUALLY CENTER MONEY SHASTA
QUESTIONS I WAS MOST INTERESTED
IN I KNOW WHEN YOU WERE
INTERVIEWING WITH- RULE STAFF
HAVE A PARTICULAR ISSUE IN MY
DISTRICT THAT CAME UP YOU. YOU
AND WE COME UP WITH THE LINE I
REALLY. THE FACT ADD UP. YOUR
OPEN TO DOING THAT AND WITH I
HAVE NO FURTHER QUESTIONS TO
LOOK FOR IT FOR TO SUPPORT YOUR
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU CENTER
WILL. THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN SENATOR ROBERT BYRD
REPROACH THEM- MISTER DIRECTOR
CONGRATULATIONS WE ARE VERY
FORTUNATE TO HAVE YOU. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. YOU AND I HAD A
VERY GOOD CONVERSATION ABOUT AN
ISSUE THAT- IS OF IMPORTANCE TO
ME AND IMPORTANCE TO THE
CONSTITUENTS THAT I REPRESENT
AND INLAND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
THAT HAS TO DO WITH THE- STATES
VEHICLE TRAVEL TRANSPORTATION
POLICY AND RELATED POLICIES
THAT ARE APPARENTLY GOING TO BE
IMPLEMENTED HERE VERY SOON. AND
THE- APPARENT DISCONNECT
BETWEEN THE V. M. T. POLICY AND
OUR STATE JOB CREATION AND
HOUSING- POLICIES AND I KNOW
THAT YOU WERE GOING TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT AND- ARE COMMITTED
TO WORKING THAT ISSUE ONE WAY
OR THE OTHER AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO. WORKING AT ALONG WITH USE
SO OTHER THAN THAT- AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS BETTER PRO TIM
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO MOVING
THE DIRECTORS CONFIRMATION AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
SENATOR ROTH I. WELL IT SITE
IT'S REALLY GOOD TO HEAR- THAT
YOU'RE IN AND SETTLED BY AND I
WANT TO WELCOME YOU OUT WE HAVE
FROM MY DISTRICT IN SAN DIEGO
PRETTY STRONG RELATIONSHIP WITH
DISTRICT ELEVEN I KNOW THAT YOU
HAVE SOME SIGNIFICANCE OF PORT
ALREADY FROM OUR REGION I WANT
TO THANK YOU WE'VE ENJOYED A
WONDERFUL WORKING RELATIONSHIP-
IMPORTANT ISSUES I HAVE NO
QUESTIONS FOR YOU TODAY I LOOK
FORWARD TO A CHANCE TO MEET YOU
DIRECTLY. MOST OUT ONE OF MY
CITIES WELL AND DIED AD GET A
LITTLE BIT OF YOUR HISTORY AS
AN URBAN PLANNER WHICH I THINK
IT'S SO IMPORTANT SO I'LL LOOK
FOR THAT CONVERSATION- BUT WITH
THAT I HAVE NO NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME BUT I DO
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU. THANK YOU MADAM PROJECT
ABSOLUTELY- I WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HERE IN SUPPORT. IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE ON NINETY ONE AND I WILL
ASK THE SPEAKER TO COME
FORWARD. AND OF COURSE TO GIVE
YOUR NAME THE ORGANIZATION AND
YOUR POSITION WELCOME. THANK
YOU SAN RECKONS A MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AYE CHRISTMAS
KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY- LA
METRO STRONGLY SUPPORTS MR-
ONLY SHOPKINS. APPOINTMENT AND
CONFIRMATION OF COURSE AS
DIRECTOR OF CAL TRANS BUT WE
SEEM TO BE A STRONG. ADVOCATE
FOR A MULTI MODAL SYSTEM OF
TRANSPORTATION IN THE STATE. I
IN HIS PRESENTATIONS OF THE CTC
AS WELL AS HIS TIME AT- AS
DIRECTOR OF CALTRANS SO FAR HE
HAS ADVOCATED FOR A NUMBER OF
ISSUES IMPORTANT TO LA METRO.
INCLUDING ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
COMPLETE STREETS ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE AND A NIMBLE AND
MODERNIZE CALTRANS AND SO FOR
THOSE REASONS. LA METRO URGES
YOU SENATOR. ANDERSON FOR HIM
AS DIRECTOR OF CALTRANS THANK
YOU MANAGER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SEEING NO ONE ELSE IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE AND
I UNDERSTAND THAT WE HAVE NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. SO ARE
A REMINDER OF FOR WITNESSES
WISHING TO PROVIDE COMMENT VIA
PHONE. OUR PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR
TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE
ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR AT THE
ACCESS CODE IS FOUR ONE FIVE
EIGHT EIGHT SIX EIGHT. FOUR ONE
FIVE EIGHT EIGHT SIX EIGHT. AND
SO I LET ME GO TO OUR MODERATOR
STANDING BY. TO SEE IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROP THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE JOINING US
BY PHONE AND IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AND IF YOU ARE USING A
SPEAKER PHONE PLEASE PICK UP
THE HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING THE
NUMBERS. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO THANK YOU WILL BE
JUST A MOMENT. THANK YOU WE GO
TO LINE NUMBER EIGHTEEN THAT IS
LINED ONE EACH PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- ANY
BERNACCHI ON BEHALF OF THE
UNITED CONTRACTORS WHO
REPRESENT MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED UNION AFFILIATED HEAVY
CIVIL ENGINEERING CONTRACTORS
IN THE STATE- WE ARE HERE- VIA
TELECONFERENCE- IN SUPPORT OF
MR ALL MY SHOCK AND-
CONFIRMATION AS DIRECTOR A
CALTRANS WITHOUT THE PLEASURE.
OF SITTING DOWN AND DISCUSSING-
THE ISSUES THAT ARE IMPORTANT
TO OUR MEMBERSHIP- IN THE PAST
AND WE LOOK FOR THE MOVE
WORKING WITH THEIR OWN SHOCK
AND- IN THE FUTURE SO. I WOULD
LIKE TO ORDER A COPY OF THE
CONFIRMATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS. WE
GO TO LINE NUMBER FORTY FIVE
THAT IS LINE FOR FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THIS IS A PIECE DONE ON THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE STUFF
HOPE TOWNIES COALITION AND WHO
HAVE THE SALES TAX INVEST
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. INTO OUR
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
EVERY YEAR I'VE HAD THE
PLEASURE OF GETTING TO KNOW AND
WORK WITH DIRECTOR I'M SHAKEN
SINCE HE FIRST STARTED HERE.
PART MEN WE ARE ANXIOUS AND-
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF HIS
WILLINGNESS TO REACH OUT. AND
BE TRUE PARTNERS WITH OUR LOCAL
AGENCIES THE SERVER OFF SAID AS
WE START LOOKING AT DIFFERENT.
MODELS THE MODES AND HOW WE-
IMPLEMENT SOME OF OUR
TRANSPORTATION POLICY GOALS.
WERE WERE VERY ENGAGED LOOKING
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
DIALOGUE ON. THE DMP DISCUSSION%
AS WELL AS OTHERS LOOKING AT.
FOR TO BE USED TO MAXIMIZE. OUR
SYSTEM AS A STATE BUT ALSO TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE- MEETING
THE OBLIGATION OF OUR LOCAL-
COUNTY PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
APPROVED BY OUR LOCAL VOTERS.
IN OUR LOCAL- SHIP WITH THE
STATE SO WITH THAT I WOULD
ENCOURAGE. YOUR AFFIRMATION OF
DIRECTOR AND JUST REALLY LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH YOU AND HE- AND WE- RIVER.
NUMBER STRUCTURE SYSTEM. THANK
YOU WITNESS. I WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER THIRTY TWO IS LINE THREE
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MADAM
PRO TEM THIS IS RAY WOLFE THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY WORST
SELF HELP COUNTY. THAT WORKS
VERY CLOSELY WITH CALTRANS TO
IMPROVE MOBILITY CHORALE
CHAMBER DINO COUNTY. I HAVE THE
UNIQUE INSIGHT AS A FORMER
CALTRANS DISTRICT DIRECTOR-
I'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH COKE SO
MUCH SHOCK IN EVEN IN A SHORT
TEN YEARS IN CALIFORNIA. I MUST
SAY THAT I'M IMPRESSED THIS
FOCUS ON SAFETY IN THIS FOCUS
ON COLLABORATING. WITH A COLD
LIKE THIS ALTHOUGH COUNTY
COALITION IS KEITH ON WISHES
SPEAKING ABOUT. SOMEONE APPLIED
GOVERNOR NEWSOME FOR REACHING
OUT IN APPOINTING TOQUES
BRINGING HIM FROM TENNESSEE TO
CALIFORNIA. I THINK- I. THINK
HOAXES GOT. I AM IN THE
DEPARTMENT CORD AND I AM THE I
SUPPORT YOUR- BUT TALKS ON THE
SHOW THIS ACCOUNT DIRECT HERE
TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS. IT ONLINE NUMBER FIFTY
THAT IS LINE FIVE ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU- THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY. MY
NAME IS HASSAN A CROWD PROBLEMS
EXPECTED THAT IT OF SOUND THAT
AGAIN THIS TIME YEAH ACOSTA
SHISHIO GOVERNMENTS. I HAVE HAD
THE PLEASURE SO ON ON ON A
WORING WITH THE ADDICT AND I'M
SHAKEN SINCE SHE MADE THE BIG
MOVE TO CALIFORNIA LATE LAST
YEAR. AND I CAN TELL YOU.
MEETING WITH THEM MIND YOU WE
GOOD HANDS. AND THE DIRCTOR
BRINGS A WOEFULLY EXPERIENCE TO
THE TABLE AND AN OVERWHELMING
AMOUNT TO ONE SHE'S AS TO HIS
WORK. CALIFORNIANS FACING MANY
CHALLENGES RIGHT NOW AS WE
BEGIN TO LOOK AT HOW OUR STATE
COULD BE COLOR. WE KNOW THAT
TRANSPORTATION WILL BE A MAJOR
ROLE. THAT IT CAN ONLY SHE CAN
HAVE THE LEADERSHIP SKILLS AND
THE EXPERIENCE TO MORE VOTER
STEP FORWARD IN A WAY THAT NOT
ONLY IMPROVED A LOT ECONOMY
PROVIDES ACCESS TO MORE JOB.
AND ENSURE PEOPLE I WANT.
PEOPLE MORE. CONTINUED MORE
EFFICIENTLY. BUT ALSO NOW WITH
THAT MEETS OUR STATE CLIMATE
AND ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS. AS WE
DO FOR CALIFORNIA THE FUTURE A
SAFE SUSTAINABLE MULTIMODAL
TRANSPORTATION. SYSTEM THAT
BUILDS ON STRONG LOCAL
PARTNERSHIPS IS MUCH
APPRECIATED. AND THAT HAS A
LONG HISTORY WORKING CLOSELY
WITH OUR PARTNERS A COUPLE
TIMES BOTH FOR THE DISTRICT AND
HEADQUARTERS LEVEL. I HAVE NO
DOUBT. THAT THIS COLLABORATION
ONE ONLY CONTINUE TO GROW BUT
THAT IT CAN ON SHE CAN HAVE
THAT HOME JUST- SOMETHING THAT
THE DIRECTOR TOLD ME NOT TO SAY
IT BUT I HAVE TO SAY IT THAT WE
ARE HIS FAVORITE TREE CHEN
PRESIDENT PRO TEM AND SIGNED
YET. REALLY SQUEEZE AND ABOUT A-
SANDBAGS. SUPPORT FROM MICHIGAN
THE DIRECTOR CALLED. I THANK.
AND THANK LET GO ENOUGH FOR-
POINTING SUCH. AN AMAZING
GENTLEMAN TWENTY IN THAT AGENCY
THANK YOU FOR THE BOOK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
BOTTOM LINE NUMBER FORTY EIGHT
THAT IS LINE FOUR EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS MY NAME IS A LEAP IT
QUITE THIS THAT I AM PLEASED TO
BE CALLING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS OF THE
ASSOCIATED GENERAL CONTRACTORS
JANICE IAN WHILE IN RAILROADS
AND TTX RAILCAR COMPANY. ALL OF
WHOM ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF MR
MUCH SHOCK IN THE POINT MEANT
AND URGE THE COMMITTEE FULL
SUPPORT IN ITS CONFIRMATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE THAT IS LINE
TWO FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE ATKINS THE
NUMBERS OF THE RULES COMMITTEE
THIS IS CHRIS WE ON THE APP OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES. ALSO
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
CONFIRMATION OF THE STROMA
SHOCKED AND AS DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION- I
WANT TO REITERATE THE POINT
THAT MISTER DUNN AND MISTER
CRIED I MADE ABOUT A MISTER I'M
A SHOCK AND WILLINGNESS TO AND-
LOCAL. HOLDERS COUNTY CITIES
ARE MAINTAINED ROUGHLY 80% OF
THE ROADWAYS IN CALIFORNIA AND
SO WE REALLY HAVE A
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM THAT
RELIES ON A GOOD PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN THE STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. WE WANT TO THANK MR
MUCH TALKING FOR REACHING OUT
VERY EARLY TO COUNTIES AND BACK
AND BRING US IN A LISTENING TO
OUR CONCERNS. WE LOOK FOR
TICKETS THE BILL. WORKING JEFF.
IN WRONGLY HEARD YOU TO VOTE IN
SUPPORT OF HIS CONCORD. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WHAT. THE LINE NUMBER FIFTY
FOUR THAT IS LINE FIVE FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JULIA RAND
OFF ON. DOG POLICY AND OUR
REACH- THANK YOU FOR THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR WE ARE
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THIS
YOU'RE ONLY SHOCKING FOR THE
DIRECTOR CALTRANS. ON HUGE
CREATED A SHIP SO FAR IN THE
ATTIC YOU TRANSPORTATION
FACTORED TOWARD THEIR ERROR AND
I THINK THE NOBILITY. THAT THE
TRANSFER SECTION TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR DESPERATELY NEEDED ON
ANY SHOWED GREAT LEADERSHIP ON
THEY'RE NOT IN DOLLARS. THOSE
WITH OUR PROGRAM WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND CONFIRMATION
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY.
MUCH NEXT WITNESS. HELLO MY
NUMBER SO THAT IS LINE FIVE
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
ANGEL ALONG BEHALF OF THE
TRANSPORTATION CORRIDOR
AGENCIES THE ORANGE COUNTY TOLL
ROAD FIFTY MILES OF TOLL ROADS
IN ORANGE COUNTY DURING THE
REGIONAL ECONOMY AFTER L. ASIAN
DIEGO NUMBER YOU KNOW RIVERSIDE
COUNTY- JUST WANTED. SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE DIRECTORS
CONFIRMATION HE'S BEEN DOING AN
OUTSTANDING JOB REALLY REALLY
SHOULD HAVE NUMBER OF THE PRO
WHICH AND ALSO WE HAVE.
DISTRICT WE'VE ALL BEEN ABLE.
TO BE TOGETHER REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES ON THE
CHIU FORTY ONE NINETY ONE A
CONNECTOR CONNECTING ORANGE AND
RIVERSIDE COUNTIES AS WELL AS
THE SHELF COUNTY TRAFFIC POLICE
AFTER. APPRECIATE DIRECTOR IT
WORK IN SUPPORT COMPANY THANK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. WHAT ARE MY NUMBER
FORTY THAT IS LAW FOR TWO
PLEASE GOING. THAT CHAIR AND-
GO COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MARK WHAT TIME. COMMITTEE ON
BEHALF OF TRANSPORTATION
CALIFORNIA AND ARE EXECUTIVE
BURKE THE KIANA VALENTINE- AND
WE WISH TO CONGRATULATE DIRECT
FROM SHOCK ON ON HIS
APPOINTMENT AND WE- WILL BE A
VERY PLEASED SEE. IF
CONFIRMATION IN OUR EXPERIENCE
WITH THE DIRECTOR WE FOUND AND
TO BE VERY COMMUNICATIVE BOB
DOLE AND INTERESTED IN SECURING
OUR INDUSTRY'S PERSPECTIVE. AND
SOME OF THE ISSUES WE DEAL WITH
ARE VERY COMPLEX- IN TERMS OF
IMPLEMENTATION- THIS WAS BORN
OUT AND WE ARE VERY GRATEFUL.
TO THE DIRECTOR THE CLASS.
WRITING CALTRANS THROUGH THE
EARLY DAYS OF THE PANDEMIC
OPENING UP SOME OPPORTUNITIES
FOR CONTRACTORS TO BE MORE
EFFICIENT IN THEIR WORK IN
CLOSING IT IS AN HONOR ON
BEHALF OF TRANSPORTATION
CALIFORNIA TO RECOMMEND YOUR
APPROVAL OF DIRECTOR CALL ME
SHARKEY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM WATER. WITNESS
YES THANK YOUNG MEN I JUST
CHECK ONE MORE TIME IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AGAIN IF I HAVE NOT ADDRESSED
YOU ALREADY AND YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN IT'S ZERO WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER TWENTY SIX THAT'S
FINE TOO. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU I'M SURE MEMBERS
ENGINE TWENTY ONE SHALL YOUR
AUNT'S WE SUPPOSE ONLINE- HERE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF OUR
DIRECTOR OVER FROM A SHOPPING
SO- CONFIRMATION ON BEHALF OF
THE FOLLOWING CLIENTS A LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI.
THE LOS ANGELES APARTMENTS
TRANSPORTATION CAN. THE PORT OF
LOS ANGELES. THE LOS ANGELES
WORLD AIRPORTS AUTHORITY WHICH
ONLY ACCESS THE LARGEST
PROPERTY. OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA REGIONAL RAIL
AUTHORITY OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
MENTALLY. NUMBER FRESNO COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY- MANY
RESILIENCY FOR DIRECTORS MAY
TIME OUT OF HIS BUSY SCHEDULE
TO ACTUALLY PERSONALLY VISITS
AND WE THANK- THE DIRECTOR FOR
THAT AND ONCE- HE'S CONFIRM AS
A DIRECTOR- COMPLETE WORK WE
WOULD INVITE THE DIRECTOR TO
MAKE THAT ARE YOU MAKING
BUSINESS ON THE STATE. AND TO
BRING THE ENERGY BROUGHT TO THE.
WITH THE RULESAND URGES COOPER.
THANK YOU MUCH ARE ANY WITH.
YES WE GOT A LINE NUMBER FIFTY
ONE THAT'S LINE FIVE ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE DOES COREY HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS FOR THE COUNTY JUST
JENNA BARBARA CAN LOSE OBISPO
AND STANISLAUS AND THE
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITIES FOR
MONTEREY. AND MARIN COUNTIES-
JUST REALLY APPRECIATE HOW
ACCESSIBLE THE DIRECTOR HAS
BEEN AND HIS WILLINGNESS TO
LEARN ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITIES
AND CHALLENGES FACING EACH WILL
BE CHEN. AND WE LOOK TO WORKING
WITH HIM TO TRUST MUTUAL ISSUES
OF CONCERN BOB AND- SAFETY. IT
AGAIN CONGESTION GREENHOUSE GAS
AND PROVIDE PROMOTE MORE MODAL
OPTIONS ON OUR TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AFFIRMATION OF HIS
CONFIRMATION THANK YOU MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS IS. WE HAVE ONE NUMBER
FIFTY SEVEN BUT AS LINE FIVE
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR- THIS
CALL MAY I JUST A BIG ACTOR
DIRECTOR OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS. CAN I GIVE THE
LARGEST MPO IN IN THE STATE AND
FACT IN THE COUNTRY AND WE
PARTNER VERY CLOSELY WITH
CALTRANS MENTALLY APPRECIATE
GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S APARTMENT OF
THE- COMMISSION ACTING AS THE
DIRECTOR CULTURE AND- I'VE HAD
THE PRIVILEGE OF WORKING JOKES.
MANY OF OUR- HE WAS INTERNET
AND ONE HOUR'S WORK A COUCH AND
HE IS ALWAYS BEING A LEADER IN
THE FIELD OF PLANNING. AND SO
IT'S REALLY TREMENDOUS THAT WE
HAVE THEM- THE TALENT COMING TO
CALIFORNIA- WE HOPE TO WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THEM- I WAS THE
EITHER YOU. THE GREAT. AND WE
USE URGE YOUR- OF COKE ON THE
AND APPOINTMENT HAS. CALLED
THANK YOU. MADAME MODERATOR
NEXT WITNESS. WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE SO PLEASE
CONTINUE. OKAY I THANK YOU. WE
WILL NOW- COME BACK TO ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE TO HEAR
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
ARE HERE IN OPPOSITION. SEE NO
ONE HERE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
ROOM ONE TWELVE IS ODD NOT OPEN
FOR OVERFLOW OBVIOUSLY SO MANTA
MODERATOR WE WILL COME BACK TO
YOU FOR VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE. WOULD YOU PLEASE PROP
THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
VET. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN THE ZERO
AGAIN FOR OPPOSITION YOU WILL
PRESS ONE THEN FZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR BY. DO YOU HAVE
PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. I DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU.
OKAY MOVE THE CONFIRMATION
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH- THERE
IS A MOTION- THING NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE RULES COMMITTEE.
MADAM SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. MONNING NINE RUNNING
I ROTH FIVE ROTH AYE WILK ALL
RIGHT LOOK I. ATKINS HI HOW CAN
I ORDERS HERE. MR ON THE SHOCK
AND YOU HAVE BEEN APPOINTED
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEMBERS
HAVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU COMMITTEE. THANK YOU WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY
LET'S SEE WE HAVE NO FURTHER
BUSINESS- IN OPEN SESSION I
WANT TO THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF
YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING THE RULES COMMITTEE.
OUR OUR WEBSITE YOUR CALL SINCE
THE TO REPORT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN
THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD.
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PART. SAY I'D IN SUPPORT OF
AINA WHO I KNOW IS- AT
LISTENING AND RECORDING- I
THINK THE- QUALITY OF THE- I
ABILITY TO HEAR AND- PEOPLE'S
NAMES IN COMMENTS WAS
EXCEPTIONALLY WELL TODAY SO ON
YOUR BEHALF I WANT TO THANK.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC FOR THAT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION OUR RULES COMMITTEE
WILL NOW MOVE INTO CLOSED
SESSION. THANK YOU.